see how many people we have online
so
all right if everyone's ready to go
representative smith
would you mind uh leading us to the
pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation
indivisible with liberty and justice
for all thank you thank you
i want to read the script required
for this meeting as chair of the labor
and rehabilitative
services committee i find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covet 19
pandemic
and accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
an executive session may follow please
note that there is no physical location
from members of the public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with an
emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during the meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to diversity
listen and if necessary participate
in this meeting by a zoom platform by
the telephone excuse me
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar of the general court website
notice of this meeting numbers comply
for house rule
rsa 91a anyone who has problems
accessing the meeting should call 271
or email hcs
ledge dot state dot nh
dot u s in the event the public is
unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned as rescheduled
christine dyer is our staff assistant
staff member member assisting us today
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
i don't have a charge
let's start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there's anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
we do not have a clerk with us so i'm
going to do my best representative
puff president
representative cahill
can't hear you michael yes uh hold alone
in the room thank you
thank you representative abellini
present at work employees around
representative nunes
good morning i'm president i'm home
alone in pelham
representative baruti um my home office
in manchester
i'm alone for now but people will be
coming in
representative smith i am alone in my
office in nashua
here representative boyd alone in my
office representative bouchard
i'm home alone in manchester
representative toomey
home alone in nashua representative
susie
present home alone representative warden
good morning home in my office in
manchester
nobody else here representative churcott
tricott here in the llb representative
seaworth representative seaworth here in
the lb
representative sullivan representative
sullivan here's the llb
foreign representative callum
here in the llb all right looks like we
have everyone here did i miss anyone
there's london oh when the
representative
don't see him either
chairman i can reach out to him i wasn't
aware that he was supposed to come so
perhaps he did get an invitation
is who are we expecting representative
prout
um i'm proud yeah proud we're going to
party to remember this committee
oh i thought you said prout i'm sorry my
apologies
anyone else unaccounted for that i did
not say
thank you
chris christina do we have the assistant
commissioner with us yet
uh mr labors is on
ladies and gentlemen where we schedule
this meeting at 10 30 uh this morning to
talk to the department of labor
um excuse me employment securities there
have been some questions that some of
you have had that you've emailed around
to the committee
regarding questions people have had
obviously there's a lot of new rules a
lot of government rules are put into the
care act
programs and there's a lot of things
going on
so we wanted representative excuse me uh
sister fisher levers
to be able to outline what they're doing
what's been going on and then have this
committee offer any
questions of the commissioner as well as
members of the public understanding that
at no time should we be getting involved
in anyone's particular case you can talk
about
possibly a an issue um
but not anyone's individual case nor can
anyone of the public come in
and ask specifically about their case to
the commissioner that's a generic
question about
procedure everyone all ready to
rock and roll
see no questions there's a
representative proud has joined us
um assistant commissioner lars thank you
very much for
joining us appreciate your time and a
very busy man
um i think i know i see you all the time
on television and everything else so
uh i know you you're out there whenever
possible so please if you wouldn't mind
giving us an
update on some of the things that your
department has been
um going through the past year or so
absolutely um first first of all mr
chairman can you hear me okay
yeah all right um it's good to see
everybody
i had a few quick slides that i thought
i could go over and share
um just showing where we're at with
claim volume and what the trust fund is
currently doing
and then i can talk briefly about
overpayments
and appeals and then do my best to
answer
all of the questions uh from any of the
members so
i'll quickly uh share my screen with a
couple of slides
there we go is it mr commissioner we've
allotted an hour and a half we don't
have to use the entire hour and a half
but i don't want you to feel you're
rushed either so
okay thank you
all right this shouldn't take too long
these are
this is from or similar to a
presentation that
uh brian gottlob and i had done earlier
this week for
senate uh ways and means um this is just
the
portion of the presentation that looks
at claim volume
and trust fund so this first slide that
folks are seeing is uh shows you monthly
initial claim numbers just giving some
perspective on
what we have experienced during
the pandemic and comparing that back to
the great recession and i say comparing
that back to the great recession you
really can't
compare them neither with the speed with
which
uh the claims increased during the
pandemic and
the heights that they reached during the
pandemic
they're really uh the they're really um
apples and oranges um when you look at
them um and
and what we've been tasked uh with doing
uh you see on that right hand side of
your screen with that
dramatic spike in those monthly numbers
compared to
back during the great recession when we
look at the weekly claims
um so on this slide these are the weekly
claim filers so people that
file a weekly claim in order to trigger
a payment of unemployment benefits
you see on the left-hand side of your
screen where we were
the week prior to the
emergency order from governor sununu
expanding eligibility
in a few weeks prior to the federal
government expanding eligibility with
the cares act so march 14th 2020 we were
just under 4 000 weekly claims
that was where we had been for quite
some time uh with
uh with you know having experienced um
the longest period of recovery um
in our history uh with the growth from
the great recession
um and then quickly um things uh took a
different turn
um we saw our claim volume spiking
through march and april and then we
peaked um with the week ending may 2nd
you see where we were just under 100
000 weekly filers so that is the single
largest week ever in the history of new
hampshire's unemployment program
um those numbers um uh then fell
through last summer and um
the fall then started to go up again
with a spike and covet cases uh with
late
fall and into the winter and then we
started 2021
um with just over 45 000
weekly filers um so a far cry
from where we were at the height of the
pandemic but
as you can see um you know
about 10 times where we were prior to
the pandemic
um looking uh to as current as we can
get with our numbers
that we have from the bureau of labor
statistics we are at 36 thousand
four twenty nine uh with the week of
april 17th
um something important to be said here
um
uh is the inside the numbers um and all
of the different
programs that are part of each of these
so
obviously with the um the pre-pandemic
number of 3909 that was all state ui
right because that was our only program
that we had available to individuals
for accessing unemployment benefits then
as we get into the pandemic numbers
these are a blend
of programs so it's both state ui for
those people
that qualify for regular state
unemployment benefits meaning they had
sufficient earnings in their four
quarter base period and they had a
qualifying separation that was
determined
not to be the fault of the individual so
the most common situation there is
some type of layoff but also we have the
federal cares act programs for
you have the pandemic unemployment
assistance program
that's the program that's created
benefits for self-employed
for gig workers and for individuals that
need to remove themselves
from the labor force due to a pandemic
reason for which eligibility was created
under the cares act
so those are folks that could be dealing
with covet themselves could be caring
for someone in the household
that has coveted prior to schools
being required to be back offering
in-person learning that could have been
apparent
with a remote learner and they are
unable to work as a result of the school
being closed could be someone that is
self-quarantined
at the advice of their health care
provider so that would be someone with
an underlying medical condition that
their
their medical professional has said um
should not
be going into a work environment um and
um the self-employed and gig workers
like i had mentioned
and then lastly the federal extension as
well
so people that have exhausted their
state ui
they transition into the pandemic
emergency unemployment compensation
program or peuc
and so when we look at a week of april
17th
2021 that 36 425
429 includes all of those programs
um that breakdown is about uh
19 000 people out of that 36 000
are in state ui and the balance
of them are in either pua which is right
around
9 000 so those are the people that are
either self were self-employed
a gig worker or remove themselves from
the labor force
um and then the balance of that is
people who have exhausted state ui
and are in the federal extension now um
as we'll see in the next slide with the
breakdown of dollars
everyone or two slides later so
um not to get ahead of myself but
everyone that's in
any of those programs also gets the
extra 300 a week
in that federal enhancement as well and
i'll show you a breakdown of those
dollars in a minute
this slide gives you a comparison
of how new hampshire stacks up against
the rest of the country
i mean we've called out our new england
neighbors
so you can see where everyone currently
sits um but what we try to do here
is give people a real good
sense of the current state
of the number of people filing
for unemployment in either state or
federal
programs as a percentage of our
pre-pandemic labor force
there's been a lot of unexplained
fluctuations in labor force numbers as
published by bls during the pandemic
they have admitted that their numbers
are less than reliable
so what we have been doing is we've been
comparing
our numbers against our pre-pandemic
labor force number
in order to remove uh some of that
unexplainable fluctuation
from bls and as you can see here new
hampshire in the red
we have the lowest percentage of people
filing for unemployment benefits
in any of the programs either state or
federal
as a lowest in the northeast as a
percentage
of our pre-pandemic labor force just
under five percent
maine you can see is the closest to us
here in new england
massachusetts is the furthest away from
us here in new england
um at just over 15 percent
uh kind of grouped in uh uh other states
that are having a
much more difficult time on getting
people back to work
and i'm going to go back to that prior
slide but i wanted to talk about this
as it makes more sense to talk about
this first this is the dollar breakdown
of the money that has been paid out of
the unemployment system during the
pandemic
so we've paid out just over 1.82
billion dollars in benefits that's more
than we paid out in the prior decade
this chart gives you a sense of where
those dollars have been sourced from
so that top line of f-puc that's the
federal enhancement program so that was
the six hundred dollar enhancement
back in 2020 that lasted until july
and is currently set at three hundred
dollars a week
that gets added to everyone that
qualifies for a weekly benefit amount in
either ui
pua or peuc they get that 300
that goes until september 4th under the
american rescue plan
we've paid out just over a billion
dollars in just that enhancement
the red bar you see is from our state
trust fund we have paid out just over
324 million dollars in benefits
uh we started and i have a slide that
will show you where we currently are
but just to not build up suspense we are
currently at
104 million in our trust fund we started
the pandemic
at 300 million uh pua we've paid out
just over 321 million dollars in pua
um importantly all of the the blue lines
here are all federally sourced
and the only state trust fund source of
payments
is that red line i'm in ui payments um
lwa
we paid out 88 million dollars that was
the lost wages assistance program that
added 300
a week to people's benefits for six
weeks back in
august and september of 2020 that was
done by presidential
memorandum at the time and then lastly
the peuc so that's the federal extension
we're looking at 58.5 million dollars
that has been paid out of that which is
uh federal as well
now going back to the slide that i
skipped over
um with regard to trust fund solvency
right now we have 22 states that have
depleted their trust funds
there they have borrowed a total of 55
or just over 55 billion
dollars including 2.2 billion borrowed
by massachusetts
this is borrowing done in order for them
to pay weekly benefits
um our trust fund remains solvent like i
said we are
currently at 104 million dollars
and we are forecasted to stay
solvent through 2021 in large measure
due to the 50 million dollars that was
provided to the trust fund from federal
cares act money
in the decision made earlier by governor
sununu
so the impact on employer tax rates that
employers have experienced so far during
the pandemic
the first impact that caused their rates
to go up was the loss of the fund
balance reductions
so that that's our statutory solvency
control
on the trust fund where when the fund
reaches 250 million
employers get a reduction in their rate
of a half
point and then at 275 million they get a
full point reduction
and at 300 million they get a point and
a half reduction
as the claim
roles increased as quickly and as
significantly as they did
and and the balance in the trust fund
fell as quickly as it did those
reductions
uh were quickly removed because the fund
was below that 250 million dollar mark
um and as a result in the third and
fourth quarters of 2020 we had a half
point
statutory surcharge on employer tax
rates
we were able to remove that effective
with the first
quarter of 2021 we don't
expect there to be any surcharges for
the remaining quarters of 2021
and importantly we never
implemented the second half point
surcharge
in statute uh so although employer tax
rates
have gone up as a as a result of the
loss
of the fund balance reductions um they
are
currently um at at uh what i refer to as
neutral
um and they're paying at the rate that's
the result of their experience
they are not having an increased rate
because of the surcharges
those are not in play right now
and again uh the the intent of
uh the money from the karzak flex fund
in order to avoid those surcharges
was so that we weren't creating a
disincentive
for employers to hire by creating by
making it more expensive
for them to bring on each additional
employee
so employers are at their true
experience rate
right now however their experience rate
is lower
right now than it would have been
had there not been additional measures
taken as a part of the original
emergency order that the governor issued
back in march of 2020
um so all of the benefits that we've
paid out that you
saw the breakdown by program normally
those that are paid out of the state ui
trust fund
those would be charged against tax
paying employers
so when i refer to their experience
their experience is
both as a positive and negative
um pieces to that the positive being we
look at what they've paid in in taxes
the negative to the employer is that we
apply the benefits paid out to their
former employees
against their experience that has not
been
going on during the pandemic so during
the pandemic
all benefit charges have been direct
charged to the fund
rather than to the experience rate of
the tax paying employers
the result of that is going to be that
as employers see their
tax rate determinations that get issued
those go out every august
and then control your rate for
quarters three four one and two um
those those determinations will not
have an increase in their experience
rate based on the benefits that have
been paid out
that that's important for keeping their
rates down
and again that's been in place since uh
march of 2020. likewise we have not been
requiring non-profits to reimburse the
fund
dollar for dollar for benefits paid out
like they normally would
so reimbursing employers like our
hospitals and other nonprofits who
normally would have to reimburse the
fund dollar for dollar that has not been
taking place
as well so that 50 million from the
cares act covered
uh that as well so that no one is
getting a free ride
on the trust fund which was created by
the quarterly tax payments from
taxpaying employers but all those are
are measures that have had impact on
employer rates
um and um i think um in large measure
what we have seen as rates have stayed
much lower than they could have
otherwise been
certainly and lower than was the
experience
from employers following the great
recession
when they were hit with both surcharges
when their experience was hit so their
experience rating was going up causing
an increase in their rates
so none of that has happened we continue
to stay solvent
and continue to forecast that we'll be
able to avoid
borrowing from the federal government
um and i think this is the last slide
and then we can get into overpayments
and
uh appeals related questions
uh this is our updated forecast um this
is from we have uh
both uh brian gottlob our director of
our economic and labor market
information bureau
and one of his economists they do
dueling forecasts
um so that we can they do different
methods in their forecasting and that
helps us with uh
to control and see how each of them are
doing how close they are
um our our band for where we expect to
be finishing 2021
uh right now is a balance between 65 to
84 million
in the trust fund and then improvements
although not shown here
but improvements going into 2022.
um so um the the fund stays
um relatively healthy compared to
everything that's going on um what we
have um
experienced during the pandemic and uh
the experience of other states and what
they have seen
so uh fortunate in that regard that
we're able to start
um with such a healthy trust fund
and i'll stop sharing right there and
i'll talk a little bit about
uh overpayments and appeals
as well um but first i'll i'll address
appeals as that's a little bit
um uh not quite as complicated as
overpayments
um but appeals are a um
um it's it's an area that is difficult
to bring on
the expertise that you need in a quick
fashion i
um compare it to
a court that's um that receives a
decade's worth of
cases in a short period of time can't
just go out and grab a bunch of judges
off the street to come in and hear those
um so it requires a certain
amount of knowledge and a skill level
that you can conduct that type of
hearing
so what we've what we've done we have
brought
in we went from 10 hearing off our from
four hearing officers rather
to 10 hearing officers currently they
are all on the docket
they are hearing cases we have
issued a request for proposals out to
new hampshire law firms in order to
supplement
our hearing officers for new hampshire
licensed attorneys
to be able to conduct hearings and issue
decisions
we felt that was a better alternative
rather than
bringing in or trying to bring in and
skill up
other hearing officers that we're only
going to need for a short period of time
the efforts that we've done in
increasing our hearing officers
have really started to pay dividends
prior to the pandemic we were hearing
uh just under 200 cases per month
uh right now we have over 500 cases
scheduled
to be heard in uh this month in may
as well as june and because of the
additional resources we've brought on
that are going through
the uh correspondence that it's received
in appeals
we have another 2500 appeals
that are able are ready to be scheduled
and are being added to the may
june and july dockets right now
so um we're going through our
our backlog that built up um i would say
over the course of the last month we're
going
through it much faster than we were
because of some additional resources we
brought on from
the vendor that supports our
unemployment hotline
i took 20 of those people and i put them
on correspondence review
so we receive a lot of correspondence in
our appeals section
about 30 of it are actual appeals so now
i have
20 additional people going through that
they process
about 32 300 pieces of correspondence a
week
and so that backlog of correspondence is
coming down
quickly that results in more cases being
scheduled
that's the 2500 that are being added to
the docket right
now um and then
um that will also probably result in
an increased number of higher level
administrative
appeals as well requests for reopening
uh cases to our appellate board
so we'll be prepared for that as well
so those are our appeals numbers
right now where things stand with regard
to overpayments
overpayments in terms of how they get
treated by the department
it depends on a host of factors whether
or not
the individual was determined to be at
fault and causing it
whether or not the dollars for which are
overpaid are from a state program or a
federal program
um so that all of that plays a role um
and
what is required to happen uh with
regard to an overpayment
so um what we have for overpayment in
terms of number of people
and the dollar amounts um for those that
are at fault so people that
made an inaccurate statement
to the department on their initial claim
or their weekly claims
um or were not uh truthful
um in the information that they provided
i can give you some examples of what
that looks like
we have about 18 million dollars in
overpayments
to that group it's about 12 000 people
they have received determinations from
the department
if their overpayment is from the state
ui
program they are
notified in that determination
that they are not at fault in the
creation of it or they are at fault
so these people would have been
determined that they were at fault
in creating the overpayment and
that they are required to pay that back
and so they then have the opportunity to
file an appeal they have the opportunity
to
seek forgiveness or compromise of that
if it's a state
overpayment and then if it's a federal
overpayment
we actually have to
the individuals if they don't go through
an appeal they have to go through
a the waiver process that's set up by
the federal government
um so with those 12 000 that i just
discussed of individuals that are
determined to be at fault in the
creation of the overpayment about 18
million dollars
so um they would not be eligible
for a waiver they can request a waiver
but if they're ultimately at fault
the waiver uh requirements and the
federal
guidelines do not allow us to waive
those overpayments
so they need to be repaid and the the
examples of that
like i said it's based on inaccurate
information provided to the department
so these are
the most common examples are individuals
who simply
misinformed the department with regards
to their separation when they originally
filed
um so there were quite a few people um
that weren't working at the time
uh prior to the time when they started
filing in fact they stopped working
in many instances back towards the end
of 19
or maybe they stopped working at the
very beginning of 2020.
when they filed with the department they
would have represented to the department
that they had a coronavirus related
separation
and that it was the pandemic as to why
they could not work
um and come and find out that once we
would
have received information from the
employer
which in a lot of cases was not provided
timely because the employers were
dealing with their own problems right at
that time
come to find out the individual would
have left employment
prior for a personal reason or to seek
other employment
and was not unemployed because of the
pandemic
and therefore would have would have been
ineligible for
for benefits um similar are those
uh the self-employed individuals that
became eligible during the pandemic
previously they had no eligibility for
unemployment
and initially when we were trying to set
them up and get them into the correct
benefit amounts
we required affidavits from
self-employed individuals
that uh where they would provide us what
their earnings were
for the prior calendar year so what they
had earned in
2019 and that was an affidavit
and then subsequent to that we received
federal guidance saying that all
individuals needed to provide
documentation to substantiate
their self-employment and so we then
required those individuals in most cases
to provide their 2019 schedule c's
in a lot of cases what came in on their
2019 schedule c
uh was much lower than what they had
represented to the department in their
affidavit as to what their earnings were
the impact of that is that they would
have been set up at a higher weekly
benefit amount as a result of their
affidavit
earnings and then when we get their
schedule c
showing much lower earnings or maybe no
earnings at
all then there is a gap
in terms of what their weekly benefit
amount should be
and they would be found overpaid uh for
that gap
so um those are um
the the common scenarios in that 18
million
that's about one percent of total
benefits that have been paid out
during the pandemic i've
i understand uh where the focus lies on
some of
on some of this but it
it is important to note that the
department did get the dollars right
and the payments right in over 97
of the cases despite having a decades
worth of volume
um and a decade's worth of payments i do
think the department deserves a lot of
credit for getting it right
um over 97 of the time um and then with
these one percent
of people that are now found overpaid
that do have an opportunity to appeal
and we're trying to get through those as
quickly as we can
they they are currently
required to repay those benefits and if
they appeal then that will be
delayed until that appeal decision um
gets issued now with the other with
other folks that are not at fault
in creating their overpayment oh of it
one important point i forgot to make
their
um the program breakdown for that 18
million
as the same for the folks that are not
at fault
about 20 of those dollars are from the
state
trust fund so about 80 percent
of overpayment dollars are from a
federal source
most of that sixty percent of it is from
the federal enhancement
um you know when that was six hundred
dollars a week and now three hundred
dollars a week
so eighty percent of the of the
overpayment dollars are federal
source dollars the other 20 are sourced
from the state trust fund
um getting to the uh
individuals who are not at fault
um in the creation of the overpayment so
it's it's in most
cases agency error we're dealing with
about 8
000 people about 25 million dollars
so there are some instances where that
is
attributed to employer error where we
could have been provided with inaccurate
earnings information but most of that
i don't want to misrepresent that and
suggest that that's
by large measure employer error it's not
most of that is
agency error and so that's about 25
million dollars of agency error so that
individuals receive money
they should not have received that they
were not eligible for
um but um through agency error
they they did get eligibility
determinations and they did get paid
now with regard to those types of
overpayments
if it is sourced from state ui the
individual is notified right in the
determination
saying hey you're not at fault in the
creation of this overpayment you don't
have to pay it back
okay we do that by state statute in
terms of
and rule on fault federal
overpayments states are not allowed to
waive
or forgive the overpayment in that
initial
determination the state is required to
follow federal waiver procedures where
we actually have to look at each case
individually first we have to look to
see whether or not they are
at fault or not if they are not at fault
we can proceed
to the second prong of the federal
waiver test which requires us to look at
their financial circumstances
and to determine whether or not
repayment
would create a financial burden on the
individual
so that is not something that can happen
in that initial determination because we
don't
have a financial affidavit yet from the
individual
so those individuals that are not at
fault in the creation of the overpayment
they receive instruction
on how to go about requesting a waiver
that we have a form available to them on
our website
along with the financial affidavit they
are then required to submit both of
those to the department
and then we look at that to make sure
that they meet that federal standard
so um it's a it's a time-intensive
process on on those waivers
i would prefer to deal with those
waivers
in a blanket fashion um but
u.s department of labor has come back to
states and says wheat and said we
cannot do that we have to look at them
one by one
so we are doing that right now our legal
section is processing
these waiver requests um and we're
moving through them
as as quickly as we can right now and
individuals as they uh receive those
notices
they get the instruction on going to the
uh
the appeal route or going through the
waiver route
and we'll be issuing those decisions as
quickly as we can
on waivers um so that uh
so all in all like i said in over 97
percent
of payments they were paid correctly
to the right people uh to eligible
people in the right amount
about one percent of payments were paid
as a result of the department being
provided inaccurate misleading
information
in most cases unless it's reversed on
appeal those people will have to pay
those dollars back
and then in about one and a half percent
of those payments
um those people were paid they shouldn't
have been paid
it's the department's fault and either
they are told in the determination that
they don't have to pay it back if it's
state ui
and then if it's a federal source
payment they are then given instruction
on
how to go about requesting a waiver um i
would expect in those cases where the
person is not
at fault as long as they complete the
form
and they complete the financial
affidavit i suspect that
in the overwhelming majority of those
cases
that the waiver is going to be granted
but again we have to do those
individually
um and i'll i'll stop there i know
that's a lot of information
um so i'll try not to keep on going
on this topic but uh mr chairman if the
i'd like to
obviously i'll stick around for as long
as you need me to answer questions
thank you commissioner um we do
recognize that you got 97
of this right you were criticized for
not paying quick enough and now you're
going to be criticized for if you paid
made a mistake that you uh
are asking for your money back so um
what's the uh expression a good no good
deed goes unpunished
so we do appreciate that actually this
is very complex
and um people have a lot of questions
and
and don't understand things so i have a
number of questions but i want to open
it up to
the members um first
are there any hints or any questions
here within the lob
uh first representative seaworth
followed by representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman and i i want to
follow up on something you said
obviously um what you talked about is
addressing
the concern from the state side of it
but if
a constituent is going to be their
biggest concern
is if they were delayed in getting
payment or otherwise
had a problem on that end
do you have kind of an overview
the squeaky wheel that's the only thing
i heard about but do you have an
overview statistically
of what happened in terms
of delays in the normal processing
where people who filed might have seen
extraordinary circumstances in the time
it took to get payment
yeah thank you representative i would
i'd compare new hampshire's record
of timeliness and payment against any
other state um
as chairman infantine had pointed out
the criticism
early on was not getting the dollars out
uh fast enough even though we were
exceeding our
timeliness in terms of how quickly we
got dollars out
as compared to the great recession even
though
our claim loads were um
in most instances quadruple quintuple
um that which we were seeing in the
great recession so i
so i think depending on the
circumstances of someone's claim
really dictates how long it takes if
they have a complicated claim with a big
payout from their employer that needs to
be
factored in by someone looking at their
claim and making sure that they don't
get paid
too much or are too early because of
that payout or they have complicated
circumstances of their separation
those types of claims always take a
little bit longer
but in a lot of in a lot of these cases
um with the particular with the agency
error
overpayments and the 25 million that's
because we paid too fast
um we we you know in hindsight if um i'd
held on to those claims for those 8 000
claims for
a few more weeks for another month and a
half or so maybe i would have been
had the information i needed from their
employer to determine that they weren't
eligible
but you know we were under a lot of
pressure to issue payments quickly and
that's what we did
with the best information we had
available at the time
knowing what people were dealing with
during the early stages of the pandemic
uh right now with the people that are
filing like i had pointed out before we
have both 34
35 000 people that are filing right now
um
in terms of timing i just had i looked
at a
claim two weeks ago a very complicated
claim someone who had been filing during
the early stages of the pandemic went
back to work
uh complicated reason for not continuing
to work
had a big pay up from that employer had
part-time earnings as they came back
and when they came back we had them back
in pace status within two weeks
um that's pretty good um considering
uh that we're still dealing with uh
volume
that's you know nine times that which we
had prior to the pandemic
so um you know we've we've looked at
timeliness compared
for the early stages of the pandemic
compared to the great recession
we know we paid faster uh the fact that
we had 25 million dollars in agency
error overpayments
that shows you that we were we were
paying a little bit too fast
in some cases um i do uh i i do think
that when you look at total
payments made by states and the
percentage
of improper payments or overpayments
that we got wrong
when you compare new hampshire against
anybody else and we and you can see that
we've got 97.6
uh of those dollars correct i think that
will stand up well against anybody else
i would caution against looking at some
of the reports that are available from
us department of labor right now
most of those are inaccurate uh and
itself you know they'll admit that those
are inaccurate because
the the reporting mechanisms that those
reports were based off
in all states had those shut off
intermittently throughout 2020
so those are not accurate portrayals of
how quickly appeals are being dealt with
or how quickly payments are going out
thank you representative sullivan
followed by representative cahill
good to see you uh deputy commissioner
um
the uh could you explain what the
financial guidelines are for the federal
waivers
what what determines whether somebody
gets the waiver or not
so the um there's not a a time deadline
for the waiver itself so when someone
receives a determination
that includes an overpayment from one of
the federal programs they have
they have language in there i'm
explaining them the waiver process
we have it on our website so there's not
unlike an appeal
an appeal someone has to file that
appeal within 14 days of their
determination
with a waiver there's not a time limit
the
standard that is in place for
considering those waivers
and determines whether the state can
grant it or reject it
first we have to determine whether the
individual is at fault
in creation of the overpayment um the
second prong if the person
is not at fault we then look at their
financial circumstances
and if repayment would create a
financial hardship
we are allowed to grant it if um
the person made
payments and decisions based on having
received those benefits
that they wouldn't have otherwise done
had they not received those benefits
that's another grounds for finding that
they meet the financial
uh part of the test and then
uh the last prong of that test is
whether
a repayment would be unconscionable
um not really any definition around that
um
states are left to implement it
as they see as they see fit but again
i think as long as someone is not at
fault um
i'm hard-pressed to think of a scenario
that they would not
also meet the financial uh burden
portion
of that standard
i'm not quite sure i understand what the
um
what you would have to see in someone's
financial affidavit to determine that
they
would not be financially uh harmed by
making repayment they have to be
here or what what what's the criteria
well you know we have to we have to know
their financial circumstances
okay that's been clearly required by the
feds and the guidance that they've
issued
so we accomplished that by obtaining a
financial affidavit which
is in the world of financial affidavits
it's a pretty short one
this is a two-page financial affidavit
where we look at household revenue
and income coming in we look at
household assets and then we look at
household expenses
so the first thing we do is we compare
monthly income against monthly expenses
that's our first review to see whether
or not we can grant the
the waiver then secondarily
we look to see whether the person has
described any decisions that they've
made
as a result of receiving benefits that
um
they wouldn't have otherwise done if
they hadn't received them
maybe they paid a large amount of credit
card debt
maybe they paid off um a
they paid a semester of college tuition
for one of their children differently
than they would have otherwise done um
those types of circumstances are looked
at
that would be grounds for someone
meeting that financial
test and then the last provision being
repayment would be unconscionable um you
know i'm careful in how this gets
applied because you know some people
just because you're you might be in good
financial condition i don't think that
should require you to pay back a benefit
that was paid to you as a result of the
agency screwing up
and so just because you might have more
income than someone else i don't think
that should be grounds for denial and it
won't be in how new hampshire
implements it but we look at all um
all portions of that spectrum so we look
at whether
you know it's going to create financial
hardship and having to pay it back
we look at whether or not you made
decisions that uh in reliance upon
receipt of those dollars that you
wouldn't have otherwise made
um and then that catch-all at the end
whether or not repayment would be
unconscionable
it's not our test right it's the it's
the federal test
we're required to implement it um prior
to
forgiving repayment of those
overpayments from federally sourced
programs
i would rather be able to waive it right
in that initial determination like we do
with state ui
but if we do that we've already been
told that it would be
held to be out of compliance with the
feds and we would not be doing those
people any favors because we
we would then be subject on audit to
having to go back
and have the people go through the
correct process
stephen one more question yes but yes i
guess based on the third criteria
um i would suggest that all that would
be unconscionable
so um provide waivers to everyone um
um representative you and i are on the
on the same page
uh there was uh the state of texas tried
doing that
following one of their because these
federal programs are
based on federal disaster unemployment
texas had
several recent disasters that required
payments
under their under federal disaster
unemployment assistance programs
they tried doing that on on one of the
instances
and tried saying that by very nature of
someone needing unemployment
that they are just assumed to have met
the financial burden
and they granted the waivers to everyone
the feds used that as an example of what
states are not
allowed to do in kind of their shot
across the bow
when they put out their guidance on
issuing waivers
one more question of the 25 million um
that was not the fault of the
recipient how much of that was federal
and how much for the state
yeah so that's a it's a 80 20 split
there so 80
is from a federal source 20 20 of that
is from the state uh so we're looking at
about five million dollars
from that total that would be
that would have come from the state
trust fund
thank you representative cahill thank
you mr chairman and thank you mr lavers
uh
over this period you and i have had many
correspondences and
conversations and uh i i also want to
recognize that the department and you
and the department have done a
great job under very difficult
circumstances and they
and to add that those claims that were
delayed were paid retroactively in full
so those people were made whole although
a little bit inconvenienced because of
the delay
quite understandable under the deluge
that you've experienced
so it appears as though with the state
with the state part and perhaps even
with the federal as long as you were not
at fault if you didn't give improper
information inaccurate information
you're going to be okay is that correct
yeah i think i think that's an accurate
statement
um you know what happens next
is determined by uh which program from
which you were overpaid
um easy if you were from state ui we
forgive it in that determination
if it's from and in most of these cases
it's not just state ui because in most
weeks you also had that federal
enhancement
um in play as well so the federal
portion of it is
is more complicated because of that
waiver process
but at the end of the day it should be
the same result
an individual overpaid from a state
program versus an individual overpaid
from a federal program
if they are not at fault the end result
should be the same
and they are not required to make
restitution to the state
um i think it's just how i go about
overseeing this part of the process i
think it's inherently
unfair to require someone not at fault
in um an overpayment uh being created
to then be expected to repay that they
didn't do anything
the agency made an error they
received dollars to which they felt and
and
thought they were eligible um
it's just it's unfortunate that the
process for waiving those
for the federal portion um requires
additional steps on the part of the
individual if there was a way of
avoiding that i would jump all over it
and there's not so we're doing the best
we can with the rules that
have been provided to us by the feds
and we'll move those as quickly as we
can and we've been
trying to make information available to
those individuals so that they know once
they submit a waiver request
um you know we acknowledge receipt of it
we tell them we're reviewing it we'll be
getting a decision
out to them they're not responsible for
making payment
during that time period so we try to be
clear
with that information that we put out to
them and we've had that type of
information
out to the public since november of 2020
just letting them know that they're
that in a waiver situation that it's
being taken and that's under
consideration
don't you don't have to do anything um
until you hear back from us
follow-up mr chairman thank you
uh in regards to the uh the gig workers
and other
self-employed and other you know
employers who are kind of
closed down or having difficulty
responding to your your questions about
claims uh
is that considered uh faults of the
the employee of the claimant if the
information didn't come back and then
you paid out several thousand dollars
uh and then you know maybe they hadn't
really misrepresented anything it's just
perhaps a misunderstanding or perhaps
their vacation pay was paid to them
in some cases they didn't understand
so if it's a situation where someone is
um
they're they are truthful to the
department on their initial filing
but because of information we
subsequently receive
from their employer that they're
determined to be overpaid that person
would be without fault
in creation of that overpayment that
would be a combination of agency and
employer error
in that type of situation depending on
the timing of when the information came
in but as long as the
as long as the info as long as the
person was
accurate and truthful with the
department they wouldn't have
a problem in that type of situation
thanks very much okay i have
representative turcotte
followed by representative attitude
representative chairman good morning
um just one quick question on your
second to last slide
uh you list the statement was there that
22 states
had depleted their trust fund could you
just send me a link to whatever
wherever you got that information or the
list or
whatever's easiest for you um the
easiest thing representative
i could i can send you the link but if
um
you if you just did a quick google
search on
title 12 borrowing and do
roman numeral 12 title 12 borrowing
it should bring you right to uh the page
that lists uh all of the borrowing
from up through the prior day with each
state
how much they've borrowed how much
they've
been authorized to borrow for the
current month
perfect thank you but i'll send that
i'll send that link out to
uh chairman infantine as well so he can
distribute it to all the members
thank you mr chairman um back
back in april of 2020
uh while the department was seeing a
dramatically increased volume
um there was giants that was put out by
then attorney general mcdonald
regarding um governor snyder's order
on uh a freeze of
investments in foreclosures uh
the attorney general's guidance
specified that
at the conclusion of the state of
emergency which we thought was going to
be a lot sooner
uh that those rents and mortgages were
tactically
full and there was no protection for
those folks
uh was there any discussion between
that you're aware of uh between the
attorney general's office
the governor's office and the department
of labor
uh surrounding the backlog of claims
and how you know something like that
a massive financial obligation like that
might be unattainable for folks that
were still waiting for queens
so there um
at no point in time have we had a
massive backlog
of claims we've had a high volume of
claims throughout
including um uh obviously
april of 2020 um but
i could go through the payment totals by
week
uh for that back then um and it would
show you that we were paying out a lot
of money
real fast um but with regard to your
question
um i did not have uh any conversation
with
uh then attorney general mcdonald or uh
with the governor with regard to that
measure no
your question was did you know any
between
the governor's office attorney general
or the department of labor this is
department employment security so
did you mean to say that yes okay all
right
and you have a follow-up yeah um
would there be any obstacles that you
could think of
um regarding permanently accepting
elderly
to gay workers um in the face of
gatework becoming more
so the question uh just to restate it to
make sure i have it correctly
so the question would be are there any
obstacles to extending
unemployment eligibility for gig workers
is that correct
i know what a gig worker is it's a guy
that maybe worked for uber or something
like that
could someone tell me what the acronym
really means
does gig stand for something actually i
think it actually comes from
like back when musicians would play out
they say
okay it's just one or two nights
sorry commissioner i just wanted to
figure to figure out what that reading
and i didn't know what the heck it meant
so
all right um when we talk about gig
workers for new hampshire
we're talking about non-covered
employment for the most part
so self-employed are are part of that
so um prior to the pandemic and the
changes that were made
only those individuals that were in
covered employment
so most w-2 employment would be
people that would be eligible for
receipt of unemployment benefits if they
had a qualifying separation and had
enough earnings
so the cares act expanded that
to both non-covered employment gig
workers and
self-employed so right now the program
under which self-employed and gig
workers are paid benefits is the
pandemic
unemployment assistance program or pua
that was the federal cares act program
that created it
new hampshire as in all other states
signed a state agreement with the u.s
department of labor
to participate in that program as we did
for the federal extension as we did
for the fpuc program the federal
enhancement program
right now that program is scheduled to
continue
until september 4th that was the
continuation from the american rescue
plan
so new hampshire participates in that
program
by virtue of having signed the state
agreement
and it continues because of the american
rescue plan so those people
right now continue to receive benefits
through the pua program without a pua
program they would not be eligible for
benefits and state unemployment no other
questions here in the lob
do i see any hands online
see representative smith warden and did
i see sullivan again
representative no representative smith
followed by representative warden
thank you mr chairman um and i am so
grateful that we have you uh assistant
commissioner uh
levers it's been absolutely stunning
working with you
i'm very grateful you came here today to
give us the numbers they really
they really show what happened last year
2020 was an amazing an amazing year i'd
just like to make sure that we get
copies of your slides please
and um i know that the calls that i
received for help
um all came early in the system when uh
your phone was just over overburdened uh
the people working there were
overburdened
and the people i heard from had complex
issues
and i'm sure that what happened was the
easy to do
simple process was managed when it came
to complex issues
they had to be thought through and there
just wasn't time
but they've all been taken care of and i
am so grateful
and really that's that's why i asked you
to come here today so i could
thank you in public thanks very much
thank you representative smith i think
we all feel the same same way
do i see any other hands okay my
questions regarding the appeals and
waivers
and the backlog how many cases do you
have in backlog
i believe you said you can handle up to
about 500
cases per month now so what is the total
backlog and how many cases
i mean how many months will it take you
to work through all those
and are the people who are waiting for
response being up
being updated on a regular basis as to
how long they should expect to wait
for a response thank you yeah so good
questions representative
um so um individuals upon the filing of
a
of a of an appeal um they are
immediately notified
of uh you know acknowledging receipt of
the appeal that we will re
we are reviewing it as quickly as
possible who to contact if they have
questions
um so we we give them an immediate
acknowledgement
um the 500 plus that we have scheduled
per month right now
that is not our capacity it's where
we're at right now
um so we've increased our capacity with
the new hearing uh hearing officers that
we've
brought on and then we will be further
increasing that capacity with the new
hampshire law firms that are going to be
brought on
as well so we'll be increasing that
monthly output
with how many were able to how many
hearings were able to conduct
we have about 2500 appeals that uh have
been uh received acknowledged docketed
and are in the process of getting a date
these are all telephonic
appeal hearings um those will be added
to may
june july probably some of those into
august
and then um like the state did with its
vaccination system as they got more
capacity they bumped up appointments
we'll be doing the same as more law
firms come on um
we'll be increasing the or we'll be
bumping up
appeal hearings to be um earlier
right now um so in terms of uh
appeal requests um those go
into for the for the overwhelming
majority of cases people
email our appeals inbox right when they
get their determination they see oh i
have 14 days this is how i can do it can
be us mail or it can be email
here's the email address boom i'm going
to submit my
appeal right now we are reviewing appeal
requests that came
in in the first half of march
and so here we are um at the beginning
of may
um that is uh uh that's the backlog that
i had spoken about that we are going
through about 3 000 plus
pieces of correspondence a week right
now with the 20 additional people we
brought on from our vendor that supports
our hotline
so that's actually um that's going uh
that's ramped up real fast since we've
brought those people on so we're
will be through march i would say within
probably
another week to week and a half and
we'll be moving into april
and those hearings are getting um
they're getting back filled into may
june july then we'll be into august
and then our effort will be to try to
move those up that
get pushed out initially when we bring
on more law firms to supplement hearing
officers
then those hearings are going to get
moved up as quickly as we can
while those people have a pending appeal
they are notified
by the department both on our website
and with
information that's sent out to them in
the determination
that if there's an overpayment that is
that's associated with that they're not
responsible for the overpayment while
their appeal is pending
we had initially um we had
systems in place that were not very
easily to shut off or to change with
regard to interest accrual
things of that nature and so initially
what we told people
um despite what you might have read in
the union leader today
what we told people back in november of
um you know in a real hidden spot right
front and center on our website
we told them we said hey ignore any
determination that you get
regarding your overpayment if you have
an appeal pending including interest
because we didn't want them to think
that we were requiring them to repay
while their appeal was pending so we put
that information out in november of 2020
we've since shut that off it took a
little while
to get the programming changed correctly
without screwing other things up
but we have that shut off right now so
that
individuals including people that don't
even file an appeal
right now they're not getting a
demand notice they're not getting a
monthly billing statement
from us because we want to get through
the backlog of appeals
before we turn that functionality back
on so we've tried to be real open
and transparent since november of last
year with regard to that so people don't
think we're pursuing collection or
having their debt accrue interest while
they have an appeal pending
all right thank you representative
cahill thank you again mr chairman mr
lavis uh so
i just wanted to refer to uh my
colleagues earlier question about the
gig workers and
the issue there is that uh if you're a
gig worker
either self-employed or for uber or door
dash or something like
no one's paying in into the system is
that not correct
correct so there they do not have
eligibility
under state ui
and so they only have eligibility right
now under federal pua which is 100
paid by the federal government if
pua were gone um if that program were to
go away
those individuals would not have
eligibility in the state
uh ui system because the trust fund is
made up of tax payments
from uh covered employers
and those the dollars that they pay in
in taxes are the dollars that we pay out
and benefits
and self-employed individuals have never
been eligible for unemployment benefits
in new hampshire
until this pandemic and um once the pua
program goes away
they would lose eligibility under
current policy
um unless obviously um uh the
legislature
made a change to that policy in terms of
who's eligible and and who
is not thank you
um mr bishop i have a few questions
i know some of these things mr chairman
representative
no i did not i apologize replied
representative avelini ebelani would you
have a question for the
commissioner i do mr i do mr chairman
thank you mr chairman thank you mr lavis
for being here with us today
i want to thank you for your help and
support um
for some of the local businesses that we
had that were having issues with their
unemployment their employees so again
thank you for all that assistance you
gave us um during this troubling time
um the question i have and i'm sure
the chairman will cover some of them
that i have as well um is when will the
trust fund be replenished
to the 300 million at the current rates
that the employers are paying
um so i'll i'll caution uh too much
reliance on what i'm going to say about
the trust fund forecast because
um our experience over the course of the
last year
really um makes you question any type of
forecast
that goes beyond certainly anything
beyond a year
is tough in terms of a reliability index
so right now we're forecasting as i
showed earlier the trust fund to
end 2021 in the range of between 65
million to 84 million
good news is that we remain solvent
without borrowing bad news is that we're
only
at 65 to 84 million at the end of 2021.
um we are anticipating further growth
in the fund in 2022 based upon
the additional hiring that we expect to
take place
um and less reliance on
less reliance by individuals for
unemployment benefit payments those
numbers have been coming down
week to week like i said before we have
about 19 000 people that are currently
filing
in the state ui program
in terms of a longer range forecast in
um
the when to expect the fund to
next uh to be at that 250 million dollar
level which triggers the first
rate reduction to employers i think
we're looking
at probably about three years before the
fund is able to grow
back up to that point and then
in order to then achieve the additional
solvency
thresholds of 275 and 300
you could be looking at upwards of five
years
but again a lot of question marks there
with regard to the the type of growth
that we see um following um
the dramatic loss of a
large segment of our labor force during
the pandemic
so it will all be determined by how
quickly new hampshire continues to
recover
thank you my recollection the last time
unfortunately i was here
through this it did take five years
understand we're only
employers are only paying tax on the
first fourteen thousand dollars
of the individual's wage so it takes a
while to catch up
once that that's why the first quarter
of every year
is the biggest revenue uh income period
for the department after that when
people reach that 14
000 they're no longer paying the
unemployment tax so the second third and
fourth quarters
money usually goes out more than it
comes in it takes a while to catch up
the questions i have for you um mr
commissioner are some things we've
already discussed but i think it's
important for
people who are listening either online
or here in the committee
one of the scenarios that occurred you
had two individuals not getting along
very well
in one employer and the employer tried
to deal with that
the one of the employees quit uh their
job
and then filed for unemployment received
the unemployment the owner
was shocked because well i have a job
for you and you have to
be available to have a job and i have
the job
why are you paying him unemployment that
really had to do with
federal money because the individual
could claim that they had to stay home
to take care of their children and such
that
the employer was not going to be charged
for unemployment on their tax rate for
that individual
is that an accurate portrayal of that
of what goes on in that circumstance yes
that's uh you've what you've said is
very much accurate so because of the pua
program
um someone could have been offered
suitable employment but
they uh qualified for pua because of one
of those cares act related reasons in
your scenario it was to care for
a remote learner that's
largely gone right now with the
governor's requirement for in-person
learning effective back as of april 19th
so that population of people that are
filing under pua
because they are the primary caregiver
for a student
whose school is closed schools are open
and we've been providing that
information to
individuals that have been certifying to
that reason
they've been receiving quite a bit of
information from us
again trying to achieve compliance
through education
and we've been reminding them the
guard rails of that type of eligibility
but once you're once the school is open
that is
no longer an area of eligibility for
someone under pua
they could have other eligibility but
that wouldn't be um
some that would not be the reason they
would now qualify for pua
since that job is still open and i
believe it's the 23rd of this month
individuals receiving unemployment are
now going to be required again to go
look for
a job and considering we have people
begging for workers in many of the
service industries
um do you expect
that as of that 23rd date if i have the
correct date
may 23rd there will be more people
coming in to
be available for employment i
i hope so um you know it's we
we turned off the work search
requirement for a year
um it feels like a lot longer than that
um
what i mean work search is a fundamental
pillar of the unemployment program i
want to deal with you
for as short a duration as possible i
want to get you back to work
our re-employment services bureau is a
critical uh component of what the
department is
all about and i'm excited to get back to
a point where we can really be
helping individuals take advantage of
the amount of opportunity that is out
there
with it seems like every business that i
drive by is hiring
right now we had a job fair three weeks
ago virtual job fair for seacoast and
southern tier employers
100 employers 3 400 openings
138 people showed up to look for work
that's not sustainable it's not healthy
it's not good i'm not doing the
individual a favor
by allowing them to easily continue to
connect collect
unemployment long-term unemployment's
not good for the individual
or the economy so getting back
to having a work search requirement
where they're they're not being required
to start working they're being required
to start
looking and to participate in activities
and make contacts with hiring employers
so that they can get back
into suitable employment we're going to
be doing a lot to educate
people in the unemployment system over
the next few weeks
every single one of them is going to be
scheduled for a virtual and
or virtual workshop where we're going to
take about a half an hour review
work search requirements going to go
over the screens that they're going to
be seeing again
explaining to them what uh
employment contacts look like what act
what types of activities qualify
make sure they understand about all of
the 10
virtual job fairs that we have over the
course of this month that is going to
cover every single part
of our state with hiring employers being
able to
showcase their positions to people that
now have a work search requirement
so we're going to be showing them and
going over all of the tools
our offices are going to be back open as
of this coming monday
uh where we can people can come in and
use our computers and our resource
centers to search for work
um but it's it's really getting back to
the way
that the unemployment program is
intended to function
states were prior to the pandemic states
were measured against one another
as to who had the shortest duration of
unemployment
and and that's because we're a
short-term
temporary financial bridge to get
someone back to work
and that's what we're going to get back
to doing and i'm excited to be able to
start working with people again and i'll
be out in all of our offices
starting next week so that we can
effectively and safely
work with with the public again
a few more quick ones you mentioned in
your testimony or your discussion
that you waived the requirement for
non-profits to reimburse
unemployment which they would normally
have to do was that the same for
municipalities or was that just for the
non-profits
it was the same for municipalities as
well okay
thank you when you talked about the
hearings that you're having uh
kind of what representative warden
talked about if there's 8 000 out there
right now you're only doing 500 a month
you know that would take you know 16
months to take care of obviously you're
hiring more individuals
how many of these hearings are for oh
just ballpark it overpayment versus
denied
currently denied for new um
people requesting yeah i would i would
say the um
um it's an important distinction they
make cause some of these are people that
just denied and they disagree with the
denial
um rather than give you a figure that
i'm not entirely
positive about let me get back to you on
that and give you a rough breakdown
of that um one just one quick thing on
that mr chairman
um there's a tremendous increase in the
number of people using the unemployment
system
and people that receive determinations
that they don't agree with that they
then file an appeal so the number of
people
has caused a spike in the number of
appeals being filed
but one thing that gets overlooked um
that's also
increased the amount of appeals being
filed is
these federal programs require us to
issue
more determinations per person
so before someone can get put on federal
pua
we have to issue them a determination
denying them state ui
some people they don't quite understand
how that process works we've tried to
explain it they file an appeal
of that those appeal requests then have
to get reviewed
they then have to get scheduled might
not be intentional the person might
have already moved on to pua but it
takes time to review all that and it
bogs things down
so there's a lot of extra determinations
that we have to issue
um on each of these claims which also
increases that claim load and that
appeals load
my point mr was that hopefully um
more deference to those that are denied
that are looking for unemployment versus
the ones that were
trying for the repayments for um which
you know obviously one is more urgent
than the other the
the next round the next question i have
really has to do with this repayment
it's clear from hearing you today that
we have the state amount and then we
have the federal amount
and we have these individuals who um 8
000 individuals
you feel it is not their fault why they
were overpaid
so the situation that has been brought
to my attention is an individual
uh had a hearing was determined he was
it was not his fault he was overpaid he
had to provide
the federal affidavit individuals like
why do i have to fight provide the
affidavit you already said i
i don't uh it's not my fault so then
um in the meantime he is still on
um unemployment a certain amount was
taken out of his unemployment check this
week
to still pay it off even though it was
waived
so obviously that's from the federal
part and
so you have to take care of both the
state park
and the federal park you make one
determination from the state
based on your own set of rules then you
have to follow the federal set of rules
to be able to waive that part and while
you're waiting for that
the state still has the ability to try
to collect some of that money back
from um so in the in the situation uh mr
chairman
with someone that i think you describe
someone who had
had had their appeal hearing and they
were determined to be without fault
right that person um unless there's
another overpayment
uh you know maybe a pre-existing
overpayment from prior to the pandemic
or something else going on they
shouldn't have
their benefits being offset in fact
i'm more than happy if you could send
that one to me so i can look at it
because we've actually shut off
our offset capability right now
however even if we hadn't shut off the
offset capability
every individual when they receive the
determination
that finds them overpaid in that
there are instructions explaining to
them
that if they don't appeal and they
continue to file
that their future payments could be
offset to repay their debt
and if they would like to avoid that
they're given instruction
right there right in that decision
saying contact this number
and they will work with you on
establishing a payment agreement
that is consistent with your current
financial ability to pay
so it's always a situation that can be
avoided
we've currently shut off our offset
functionality
right now but as long as someone reaches
out and follows that instruction on the
determination
they should not be having um that a
large
portion of their unemployment benefit
offset to repay a debt
i will get that information over to you
the last thing i would request
if you would send along also a copy of
your powerpoint presentation that you
presented to us so i can get it to the
rest of the committee
there are a lot of good helpful numbers
that we can share with our constituents
i want to keep within the noon time here
i am
finished with my questions any other
questions here in the llb
seeing none any online and last final
questions for the commissioner
all right well thank you very much um mr
commissioner we appreciate it uh
we uh we all think you're doing a very
good job
uh the fact that you're you're you're
very polite you said 97 was 97.6 some
people would
some people would round that up to 98.
so appreciate your
appreciate your candor um and um
and the fact that you are trying
the best you can to get additional
employees
or law firms in to the department to
help with these um
overpayments one of the only other
things um
something i would ask you to to work on
and i understand you're doing the best
you can
one of the complaints i had is that
sometimes very difficult to get through
on the telephone
and talk to someone that knows what
they're doing
or at least i take that back that was
incorrectly stated getting to the right
person for their issue
um is it easier and
more efficient for you folks if they
email versus call in
um the call-in is still the best way the
way that the hotline currently works
is we have it's a tiered structure i'll
be i'll be brief with this mr chairman
um we have a vendor on tier one that all
the calls go into or the
or the line share of the calls go into
um they've been
uh skilled and trained on how to handle
most uh basic unemployment related
questions
uh we give them weekly sometimes daily
training on current hot topics and what
we see for
uh topics for that are causing a spike
in calls if they cannot handle it they
then transfer it immediately to tier two
tier two or department employees these
are all of our staff
in the local offices that are spending
their days
on the phone answering questions so
uh we have about ten thousand calls a
week right now that we're receiving
um four to five thousand of those end up
getting
transferred in and handled by our local
office staff
so um that's the best route for getting
a question with regard to your
eligibility answered
now what i've found because a few people
have my email address
um it tends to get plastered all over
social media
um i can't keep my voicemail
down to a number that i you can leave a
message um
when uh those people that they complain
to me about the hotline it's not that
they haven't been able to get an answer
they don't like the answer that they've
gotten
and so sometimes i'll be the first to
admit
the vendor staff that we have who have
been quickly trained up
sometimes their the answer they provide
could have been better
and the person is rightfully um agitated
um by the lack of
being able to get the answer they need
other times
it's they the answer that they got is
not the one they wanted
um and that's important to remember
excellent well thank you very much um
we appreciate that uh you have a great
day commissioner
uh members of the labor committee we
will resume at one o'clock for
house senate bill 137 at two o'clock for
house
senate bill 123. we'll keep the zoom on
and the volume off here in the lob
and we'll see you in about an hour enjoy
your your lunch
thank you everyone for participating
thank you you take it inside
oh
thank you
let's see
is the ball you want can everybody hear
us online
yes okay there had been an announcement
uh made by christina dyer that
we did not have um
[Music]
a live capabilities to listen to
our first part of our hearing
on uh youtube i did receive a text about
10 minutes into
uh the discussion with the commissioner
that we did have that access back
so in case anyone was wondering it was
only we were having technical problems
but that was resolved pretty quickly
so is everyone here we've got
uh one minute christina uh
there's a gentleman a
and lobbyist to sign up who will be
raising his hand
[Music]
because at this point i have seven
individuals
that have signed the
[Music]
okay great thank you
it is now one o'clock
all right you're all set yeah i am now
all right excellent it is now one
o'clock we are going to open this
hearing the house labor committee
hearing on senate bill 137
relative to the minimum hourly rate for
tipped employees
and i
have some representatives and senators
listed
um
so christina can you let me know who is
who's online
senator bradley representative horgan
representative horrigan is here
uh we have alicia preston curtis berry
heather goalie henry villa catherine
cummings
representative chris schultz rick newman
and rudolph alden
okay i think i know everybody there but
i don't have a
presenter for the bill
so um i would
senator pardon i'm
well i'm going to um i'm going to punt
here
would any of you like to represent or
see with would you please
introduce house bill 137 for senator
bradley
i would be happy to uh representative
brian seaworth from pembroke
representing the district that has been
broken
chichester and i
would like to introduce senate bill 137
relative to the minimum hourly rate for
tipped employees
thank you very much
thanks sorry alyssa from a standpoint of
representatives is representative
timothy horgan representative you're
recognized to speak
okay i'm uh i was i'm surprised that i'm
the first one
speaking but i'm opposed to senate bill
137 for the simple reason that it uh
lowers the min the wage for tips
employees who are often um
we found out how valuable they are
during the pandemic which is still going
on but uh
you know they're they're underpaid
they're overworked they're
underappreciated and this just
pays some uh pays them less and then
also the whole uh you know because the
327 an hour
basically um senator bradley is not here
to explain why he did it but
that is about 45
of uh current 725 and certainly
i assume this is going to assume this is
in anticipation
of the possibility that the federal
minimum wage which is also our statement
in the wage will be uh
will be will be increased um so that's
uh
and also like probably think a lot of
the other things in rsa2789 21
need to be changed but this bill just
affects that one thing so i think that's
not a good change if you're going to
change it at all the
uh base rate should be higher in fact it
probably should just be
the federal minimum wage and then the
tips are on top of that so i think that
with the tips um i think basically the
way it works the base ways is what the
uh
what the owner of the restaurant or the
other facility
pays you to be there even if there's no
customers there and then um
the tips are on top of that are for
providing
the service for the employees and it's
kind of a strange way
to compensate people but that's what
evolved and um
some ways i'm glad to do it because at
least i can uh
i can make sure they're paid leaves a
little bit more than the uh
the absolute minimum so that's uh i mean
i do understand the uh
tourist industry is a key industry in
our country
in our especially in our country in our
state but actually
uh they're having trouble finding
employees one of it may be because the
pay rates are are too low given the uh
what the labor market is like because
we're having so i
i say this bill uh still
been it out in the past and um it should
be it'll begin so that's uh
that's basically all i have to say about
it i'd probably probably much more
go on more about the technical details
than i can but if you want to ask me a
question i'll know
you can do so thank you representative
any questions here in the lob
seeing none of any questions for the
representative online
i don't see any thank you representative
oregon well thank you thank you
senator um bradley is with us senator
senator bradley
there you go sorry about that mr
chairman and i apologize for being late
um so
pleased to be here in support of uh
senate bill 137 which the senate passed
um this is a very simple bill and it's
also a very important bill um
especially with the discussion in
washington about raising the minimum
wage to 15
an hour while it hasn't happened yet
certainly it could and there are a lot
of people pushing for it
what that would mean given our
tying of the minimum wage in new
hampshire to the federal minimum wage
would um be nearly or actually more than
a doubling
of the current tipped wage to i believe
6.75
cents an hour by virtue of the fact that
we are tied at 45 to the minimum wage
i think we all are very very aware
of the duress and the ongoing pressure
that um our hospitality industry and
particularly restaurants are under
and are going to continue to be under
many of them have barely survived if
they've survived at all the pandemic
and the potential of more than doubling
the tipped
wage is something that could put
many restaurants under the
just continued duress and and cause them
to fold
there was a lot of support in the senate
amongst the hospitality industry for
this
i think you will hear that discussion
today
from many of the same folks that we
heard the discussion
the one um thing that i would add mr
chairman
is the contingency section on line 19
and 20 of the bill
that um this only takes effect
if the minimum wage is raised federally
so if nothing changes
nothing changes in new hampshire the
only other thing that i would add mr
chairman is
everybody knows that the vast majority
of a
tipped employee's salary comes from
tips not the minimum wage and so by
raising the cost
as this would do if the federal minimum
wage went up in new hampshire's law
was not changed would force
employers in the hospitality industry to
move
to more tablets replacing people
and downshift or reduce hours
reduce the number of shifts it would
probably lead to
job loss and there would not be
a corresponding gain for an awful lot of
people that could
well find themselves out of work if this
happens
raising the minimum wage as i've always
said is well intended but it has
that consequence of job loss we want to
make sure that
our hard-working restaurant owners
are able to survive this pandemic and
survive
a doubling of the minimum wage without
the tipped wage in new hampshire going
up so
i support the bill obviously and happy
to answer your questions
thank you senator bradley questions in
the lob robertson vatican
thank you mr chairman um thank you
senator bradley i would
beg your patience as i have a couple
questions to go for you
um i'm looking at line nine
uh in bill tipton
line eight tonight tiff's employees were
licensed as secondary game operators
pursuant to rsa 2017
um uh would receive a base rate from the
employer not less than 7.5 an hour
um could you define
um what a secondary game operator
pursuant to that rsa
is and why uh the senate felt an
appropriate intimate a special part of
that
in this legislation so we
made that addition to the legislation
as a result of
the secondary game operators coming to
us
and saying they had tipped employees
that would be subject to the
minimum wage increase so we added that
in
per their request since they are also
tipped wages we did the same with cigar
bars
again um the same rationale
thank you i understand including them
um but it seems like based on the
language they would be making
more um securely
uh without the compensation tips than
they would
uh were they restaurant workers is that
not the case
i'm sure that somebody representing
the secondary game operators and the
cigar bars will testify
um and i guess i'd ask you to ask them
that question
follow up um you mentioned
in your testimony of the potential
downsides
to increasing uh the minimum wage
would have on restaurant employment
however a study from the economic policy
institute suggested that
the seven states that don't have a
separate tip to minimum wage
are all currently experiencing higher
restaurant growth rates
and have the same higher rates of
tipping as the states with a sub-minimum
wage
do you feel that's accurate or no so i
think that
um the senate heard testimony and you
certainly can pull up the hearing report
and i suspect you'll hear testimony
today
from restaurant owners i mean that's um
you know the most accurate summation i
think of
what they're feeling and what they're
facing if the minimum wage increases
and so the senate uh wanting to protect
them
and protect those jobs and to try to
keep them viable
that's why we passed this bill
one last follow-up thank you mr chairman
um
again looking at the bill uh reading
from line
15 if an employee shows the satisfaction
commissioner that the actual amount of
wages received at the end of the day
period did not equal the minimum wage
for all hours work
the employer shall pay the employee the
difference to guarantee the applicable
minimum wage
given that new hampshire doesn't have
its own minimum wage
the supremacy clause the constitution
defers that we follow to
the 725 minimum wage
it is an employer not just making up the
difference between
the tips and fifteen dollars an hour
regardless of what the base minimum
wage is set at because it just feels it
just feels like it's the same
amount of money and the employee would
be making that closer to 15
an hour anyways and this just feels like
a very
hat on a hats kind of reach after that
well
first of all representative lines 15
through 18
are existing statutes so um
this isn't changing that
understood
i guess that's it okay
uh questions here in the llp uh
followed by turcotte
thank you mr chair um senator bradley
uh thank you for coming today just have
a couple questions
uh just for my own edification uh in
your testimony
mentioned um that
if the minimum wage which we follow is
federal
um where it were to go up and double
that you know uh
potential job loss uh potential uh
businesses would be under a hardship
would be uh
hard to maintain costs
might even put them out of business my
question
is
that would occur to all businesses
so why is this bill singling out a
certain
subgroup of people to uh protect
well the reason for that representative
is that
our statute in new hampshire ties
the minimum wage for tipped employees to
of the applicable minimum wage so
my understanding is the
federal tipped minimum wage
is actually below our 327
mark now if the federal if congress
also raises the minimum tipped wage
federally
then obviously that would supersede new
hampshire law
but if it leaves it alone the fact that
our 45 percent
of whatever the federal minimum wage
would more than double it so that's why
uh the carve out obviously you know
there's been a debate
for many years in new hampshire about
raising
the minimum wage and as i think i
indicated before
it is well intended some people benefit
but then especially entry-level workers
first-time
job seekers um who
need that first job may get priced out
of
that first job with an increase in the
minimum wage
but that's a different debate
that's a debate about the overall
minimum wage this
is just about tipped employees
remembering the vast majority of a
tipped
um employee's salary should be from tips
not you know the stipend that they're
paid and
but at the same time the cost of
restaurant tours
by doubling that is going to lead to
price
increases perhaps less tips less jobs
and an overall problem i think for the
restaurant
industry in new hampshire and that's why
you know this is a narrow bill not a
broad bill on the minimum wage it's
specific
because new hampshire has that 45
percent
um you know tying to the federal minimum
wage
thank you representative followed by
representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
bradley uh one question
on uh beginning on line 11 and going to
14 there's a
paragraph that starts with if such an
employee shows the satisfaction
on and on and on uh further down in line
14 through 18 there seems to be almost
duplicative
uh wording can you explain
is there a difference there honestly
i've read through that about 10 times
and i'm trying to figure out
why that both those uh paragraphs are
there
i'm sure i'm looking at it too
so i know that in the senate
test uh hearing um
there was testimony from the department
of labor sorry to deflect that question
but um it might be better to
ask the department
would you repeat that i i don't follow
you representative
if you start on line 11 mr chairman
where it says
if such an employer shows to the
satisfaction
and that continues in bold through line
four it does look to be the exact same
language
there's a very very very slight
difference but
to me the intent is the same so i'm
trying to figure out if there was
actually an intent or if it's a drafting
error or just
it just doesn't look right to me going
further mr chairman on line
14 at the very end it starts again
if an employee shows to the satisfaction
on and on and on
and again other than i don't even
remember one or two
minimum one or two word differences it's
the exact same
intent i believe but i must have the
wrong i'm looking at
uh amendment to senate bill 137
amendment 2021-0983s
correct
okay i want to make sure we're actually
i think what we should be looking at is
the
sd-137 as a
i didn't hear what you said
representative sullivan
looking at sp 137 as amended by
okay and i think perhaps i'm guessing
that when the amendment was incorporated
into the bill
as amended it was done in property
all right we're
as written it doesn't appear correct so
all right we will thank you mr chairman
this is
uh jeb again i think uh the questioner
is correct
um it appears to be a drafting error but
um
i trust you folks to sort that out
trust thank you yes trust
representative seawork thank you mr
chairman and thank you senator
um this may be another one of you that's
worth deferring uh to someone later
my question is also on line
11 but the first part of that line
where and in some of the testimony we
talked about
what the different minimum wages would
be for tipped employees
this seems to introduce a new one
at 7 25 an hour that is neither
45 of the new one nor
is it the old one and it
again it seems strange to me for the
particular class of
secondary game operators to introduce a
minimum wage that doesn't match any of
the others
so from the standpoint of the senate
amendment
is there an intent there that we should
be aware of or is that something i
should bring up with
uh you'd probably be best advised to
bring that up with the
representatives of the tipped employees
for
secondary game operators because this
was the language that they
asked us to insert and it may be
pursuant to the existing rsas
all right
all right that's all the questions here
in the lob the questions online
please anyone
uh representative bouchard you're
recognized
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
uh senator have have you seen
the studies that are out there that show
that when you increase
wages that you increase the productivity
of the employees
and you lower the turnover rate which is
a
very big cost to an awful lot of
restaurants to be able to train
employees
thank you for taking my question so i'm
sure that if the
uh restaurant owners thought it was in
their best interest
financially they would
raise that tipped wage themselves
that being said certainly the testimony
in the senate revolved around you know
the financial duress that would put many
restaurant owners
under given the vagaries and the
pressures that they faced um through the
pandemic and the fact that
even as you know people are starting to
get vaccinated and go back to
restaurants now
it's still a diminished diminished
capacity
um you know in their business it may
change
but i think they feel the duress and
they've been under that duress for a
long time and so
um i think the senate took that
testimony
seriously given the pressure that
restaurants are under
thank you senator
thank you um any other on our
representative
cahill thank you mr chairman
and uh thank you senator bradley uh i
know you're you've
expressed a concern that if the wage the
federal wage goes to 15
that it would double the tip rate
it may be unlikely it may only go to 11
or 12. do you have a contingency for
that
would would it not be more in line more
reasonable to have
if it went to 12 it would be like and
forty cents an hour
and again this is only paid it's only
making up the difference when the tips
were so
which we're told the tips are twenty
dollars an hour it's only when the tips
aren't twenty dollars an hour
but the employer has to make up the
difference would
would that be reasonable to havoc uh
maybe i know that there was a bill to
lower the percentage uh
you know in the event maybe it could be
scaled down a bit
um there's you know in my
view i mean obviously it would have less
of an impact
on a restaurant owner but
just reading the tea leaves
i think the pressure is on
to raise the minimum wage to at least 15
an hour
and there's as much pressure to raise it
higher than 15
an hour in washington as there is to be
somewhere between 7
25 and 15. so what happens who knows
regardless tipped employees
you know while this you could argue
would benefit them
even if the minimum wage say went to 12
not 15 and their
um percentage went to about six dollars
as opposed to
675 it still would be a big cost on
restaurants
and i think what you'd see is the
corresponding move
to you know reduce shifts reduce
hours and use technology whenever
possible to replace
um wait staff and and you know we've
certainly
seen that in areas of the country that
have
raised the minimum wage significantly
some people have been helped
no question about it if you're somebody
that
you know has a job and your wage has
gone up
as a result of the change in law more
power to you but if you're somebody who
has lost their job because they've been
priced out of the market or you're a
first-time
job seeker that is suddenly priced out
of the market
they're losers too and i think um
that's always been my concern with
raising the minimum wage
i mean as as i think we all know right
now
um there are thousands of jobs
um available in new hampshire and so
anybody that wants to work
can work but restaurants are under
undue pressure because of the pandemic
that
is going to be with us i think for quite
some time
and the potential of this burden on
restaurants
i think when you hear their testimony i
hope you feel compelled as we were
in the senate knowing that you know
lines 19 and 20 the contingency language
nothing changes in new hampshire unless
the minimum wage increases in washington
thank you senator so this is willing
from time
uh i was reading the senate testimony
are we the only state in new england
that has
a tipped wage that has a percentage of
the the minimum
i i'm not certain of that but i believe
that to be the case
thank you representative alligent you
have another question for the senator
uh thank you senator for taking the
question um as was pointed out
correctly by representative richard
there
uh regarding turnover and uh
savings from that in the restaurant
industry in fact one that i
want to stop ask a question please
i'd like to have a lot of latitude on
this representative over the last couple
weeks
please ask a question instead of making
making your point
of what you want to get in there and
then asking the question off that please
uh would you believe that there are
robust studies employment
in restaurants regarding minimum wage
increases then they suggest that wage
increases get absorbed by finer
price increases that do not impact point
of order
this was specifically brought up uh by
the clerk
of the house that the use of
would you believes are not appropriate
in
hearings the purpose of hearings are to
receive testimony
and ask questions of that testimony
but what do you believe is making a
comment made in the statement to the
individual
that the individual wants to get out
there this is
this the the line that uh representative
adjutant has taken is not
appropriate for this senate understood
thank you that it was what was presented
by the clerk
please ask your question but definitely
please okay i was not aware of that
so i'll take that into consideration um
i want you to ask your question
representative i just want you to do it
in a way that's
acceptable thank you senator bradley
do you believe
that there might be a difference
between what is most beneficial
in the best interest of a restaurant
worker
versus the interest of the restaurant
owner
well i think as i've tried to answer
this question
the minimum wage creates winners and
losers
and if your wage goes up you're clearly
a winner
but if you've lost your job due to
technology
or less hours or fewer shifts
because the cost to the restaurant owner
that creates losers
too and so i've always been very
concerned
that raising the minimum wage and while
this is a subset of it
does create winners and losers and in
particular
and restaurants are really good at
hiring
first time job seekers
i mean that that is a staple for many
restaurants
and they are often at tipped wages
and if they're unable to hire as many
people
then people lose too and that's my
concern
thank you one more question
representative
thank you uh mr chairman uh senator this
is just
i just want to be clear on on
state and federal it's my understanding
that new hampshire defers basically to
the federal
minimum wage as we don't have a statute
defining the federal
defining our own minimum wage in this
bill there are there is a number
proposed as opposed to a percentage
which effectively would freeze that
minimum wage
my question is is how does that play out
can the state of new hampshire supersede
federal
or can or does federal supersede state
well i think i answered that if the feds
raised the tipped minimum wage then
this debate is over but in the past
my understanding representative is
congress has raised the minimum wage
without raising the tipped wage
so this bill only applies to that
circumstance where
congress were to raise the minimum wage
and leave the tipped wage unadjusted but
because of the 45 percent provision
in new hampshire law then our minimum
wage in that eventuality
would more than double if the feds raise
the tip minimum wage
this debate is over they raise
thank you senator
see no other hands senator bradley thank
you for your testimony
thank you very much mr chairman and uh
again i apologize for being late
no worries uh next up is representative
tony kaplan
uh merrimack district six
representative are you with us
i do not see him let me know uh by a
text if he comes back on please
um the next step is henry value uh new
hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
uh mr value
thank you uh mr chairman uh and members
of the committee
for the record my name is henry value
and i'm here on behalf of the lodging
and restaurant association uh
we asked uh senator bradley uh to bring
this bill in
um and it is it's pretty straightforward
um
as you can see it uh the big change is
changing the
how to figure out the employee tip wage
from a 45 percent of what the applicable
minimum wage is
and instead replacing it with an
absolute number
of 327. mr chairman you asked
about new hampshire and
whether other states have a percentage
as we do here in new hampshire uh
calling it 45 percent of the applicable
minimum wage we are the only state in
the country
if you look at all the other states they
have an absolute
number in statute um so by moving from
this
sliding percentage uh
to an absolute number will be more in
line uh with
the rest of the country 45
of the applicable minimum wage today is
so we are proposing to keep it
there um you know it's interesting that
uh
the tipped employees are in the minimum
wage statute
um because while the minimum from the
employer is 327
their total wages on average are between
20 and 22 dollars an hour so they're
actually the highest
paid in a restaurant
if you were to go into the back of the
house the restaurant
and talk with the dishwasher who's maybe
making 12
an hour and ask whether they'd prefer to
make
the 327 and then chips on top
i think the answer you'd get is they
prefer to be a tipped employee in the
front of the house
because again those are the highest paid
employees and they deserve it because
they do a great job
but when we talk about tipped employees
they are not minimum wage employees
and um so uh
again we are looking to uh freeze it
in this bill as represented as senator
bradley mentioned this
only will go into effect if
the federal minimum is increased in i
think
um you know it's an agenda item of uh
this administration in this congress so
i think we expect it to go up
um and but this bill only
addresses the tipped employees um
there was an effort there was actually a
bill that passed if you google
uh minimum wage tip wage
main state of maine uh you'll find
uh stories from several years ago where
they did away with the tip wage
uh they basically uh
required restaurants to pay the tipped
employees
the minimum and you'll find in those
stories
that it was the tipped employees the
following year
that convinced the legislature to go
back to the way it was
because they were all worried about
losing their tips
again they make the majority of their
wages by tips if
if it's 20 to 22 an hour that the
average
taking home obviously it's seven you
know to 19
17 to 19 dollars that they're making
from tips
an hour and that is that's that's the
bulk of their pay
and those are wages uh if you look at
279 26 b
which addresses tip pooling and sharing
uh the first part of that statute says
tips are wages uh and shall be the
property of employee
so the and and um employers must pay
uh the social security taxes on those
tips
so the employees must report them to the
irs
as wages um so while we're
talking about the minimum wage statute
um this
issue in this bill is not really about
minimum wage workers
and i'd just like to answer a few other
questions i know representative turcotte
brought up a
very good question um and i would agree
i think this
was just a drafting area because if you
look at
the language in the bill is amended by
the senate
that is not in bold that's the current
statute
when they added in the language in bold
i think the drafter
in legislative services must have wanted
to make sure
that the tipped employees that are
secondary game operators
uh were also going to be making
the difference between the 327
and the minimum hourly rate so that that
sentence that's addressed twice probably
doesn't need to be there that
probably something to check the
legislative services on
the question that represents seaworth
had about
um the 725 dollars per hour i'll let the
secondary game operators
answer that question but i believe that
they have that in there as 725 right now
because that's what secondary game
operated tipped employees are paid right
now as the minimum
because they're not uh considered tipped
employees right now so they're paid the
seven
they have to be paid the minimum of 7.25
so i think the goal uh certainly the
goal with the restaurant folks is not to
decrease
the minimum wage from the employer so
that's why we're proposing 327
and i think in the secondary game
operators
instance their currently minimum is 7.25
and i think
those folks are looking to keep it and
not reduce that so
this basically would keep the status quo
uh no one's wages would go down uh
tipped employees actually
see their wages go up every year uh
menu prices increase on average about
five percent a year
and tipped employees are paid
uh as a percentage of the full price of
the menu so if you tip
20 um every year
that that meal price goes up five
percent
um and so the employees wages uh go up
so there's already
uh this uh mechanism
in which uh tipped employees wages go up
annually
anyways um so with that
um i guess uh oh representative huff
asked a good question about
the tip wage and the federal wage
the federal minimum
for tipped employees is two dollars and
thirteen
cents our new hampshire minimum of 327
is higher than the federal but as
senator bradley mentioned
if in congress uh this year they
increase the tip wage
uh above 327 then we would have to
um you know comply with the federal law
so
we're cogniti you know cognizant of that
but
there is the same discussion going on uh
in dc about
the tipped employees and tip wages uh
and our
uh two senators uh shaheen and hassan
are very much involved in that
discussion
i think they recognize the uniqueness of
the industry
um and i guess with that i'd end
my testimony and be happy to answer any
questions
mr v this is willing from time one of
the questions that representative
edition asks had to do with
um the payment of the wages if someone
does not make 7.25 an hour
uh it's a slow cold rainy day and no one
comes in
um and if this bill passes they would
make
327 an hour the employer would have to
find out what they need for that period
of time
and pay them 725 an hour or the
difference between what they earned and
the 7.25 an hour
they would have to pay them the
difference to make sure that they made
the 725 but i
i would ask the department of labor if
they've ever
come across that circumstance i don't
know of any restaurant in which
um you know a because they staff
restaurant staff
to what they know their um
their activities going to be um after a
while you get to know that thursday
night's a busy night i'm going to need
more
tipton i'm gonna need more weight staff
uh you know a monday night
is slow i probably need a third of the
wait staff
uh so it's i'm not aware of instances
where
uh a restaurant has had to make up the
difference because a tipped employee
has not made at least 7.25 you can ask
the department of labor uh that if
they're on
they may be aware of it but um but that
language is in the statute
just to make sure that no one makes less
than the minimum wage
but as i as i mentioned before tipped
employees are not minimum wage employees
they are
the highest uh paid uh employees
no just up so um federal minimum
wage for tipped employees is two dollars
and seventeen
cents we are proposing three dollars and
twenty seven cents
we are proposing three twenty seven
because effectively
that's what it is today because 45
of the federal 725
is 327. so we are proposing
to keep the tip wage for tipped
employees
at the same amount that it is today
if the federal government decides
if we pass this bill and they decide
it's 10
minimum wage is ten dollars an hour
they will they also come up do they
normally come up with a tipped wage
also and that we would have to adhere to
both of those
they very well could change the way so
right as i said
you mentioned the federal minimum on the
tipped uh
wages uh i thought it was 213. you
mentioned 217.
see the 23270 whatever it is um
if they don't do anything on that then
new hampshire's 327 would be the floor
that uh a business would play pay the
tipped employee
if on the other hand uh the feds
in addition to increasing the minimum
wage to 10
12 15 whatever it is they also
increase the tip wage from 213
to a higher number uh and if it's higher
than 327 then new hampshire restaurants
would
have to pay the higher federal minimum
wage this 327
would be trumped by the higher federal
minimum as representative bradley
as senator bradley said he said you know
this this
this what we're doing here with this
bill could be trumped by what happens in
dc
if in fact they changed the tip wage
which is currently 2 13.
thank you just uh i i asked christine by
a text or
to come up to some of the chart there
are seven states
uh in the country that um have a
percentage
of their tip wager percentage thank you
uh there might there are some more
questions for you mr babe wherever
somebody did
thank mr chairman and thank you mr
pendleton for taking the question
um what is the source of the data that
suggests
that the average wage for tipped workers
in hampshire is over 10
hours i believe we've gotten it from
employment security they keep a lot of
information there on wages
rudy ogden from the department of labor
so maybe we'll ask him that question
yeah do you have any additional
questions well i just it's
a question i have data from the bureau
of labor
and and and i'm talking new hampshire i
mean uh
as well cooking um
well we'll see if uh
any questions here representative
thank you um
uh thank you mr uh villa
i'm sorry
uh um i'm not sure if you'll be able to
answer this but
it's just occurring to me what would be
the purpose
of new hampshire having a higher tipped
minimum wage than the federal
when we don't do that with the
non-tipped
wage um
so years back we had both a
minimum wage for hourly employees and we
have
the tip wage i think it was what 2012 or
something when
our hourly minimum wage
um that was repealed and
we then fell to the federal statute
um i guess there was uh
a recognition then uh
that if we also repealed
the tip wage at that time
then it would have gone down to the 213.
we've always been higher than the
federal 213
and so uh i don't think anybody wanted
to
reduce uh anyone's wages
and i think that's why um because when
they repealed
the hourly uh new hampshire's hourly was
and the federal was 7.25 so repealing
new hampshire's
for all intensive purposes really did
nothing because we still had to comply
with the federal 725.
if you repealed the 45
of the applicable minimum at that time
you would have done away with our 327
and it would
have gone down to 213 which is what no
one wanted to do
so i believe that is to answer your
question that's
why uh we have a higher
um tip wage because
historically we've always had a higher
tip wage than the federal one
um so what i'm gathering is
is the reason that this and correct me
if i'm
not picking this right um
the reason that this bill is coming in
is to protect
the businesses from paying in theory a
higher minimum wage
so why would they be against lowering
the minimum wage
if we were to just go strictly with just
what the feds say and not have this 45
the interest in the industry in this
bill
is to prevent the minimum tip wage from
going
up um when the federal
uh minimum increases uh
because as as you see the statute it
says 45 percent of the applicable
minimum wage so
if the federal minimum wage increased to
15 or 12 dollars
the tip wage in new hampshire would
increase
to 45 of whatever that federal minimum
is
um so um
we have no interest in reducing anyone's
wages we essentially just want to
keep the status quo on the minimum from
the employer but again
tipped employees wages go up annually
because menu prices go up
five percent on average every year and
they're paid as a percentage of the
price of the meal so
their wages go up annually
thank you thank you welcome
questions online
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
veyu good to uh hear you again i can't
see you from here but uh
um so we we tip 20
generally on the price of the meal
so this leaves us with a situation where
a
server carrying you know a tray full of
pancakes and eggs anyway you like them
and coffee
is making quite a bit less than the
person in the high-end restaurant
doing very similar work have any comment
on that
uh certainly high-end uh
server servers working in high-end
restaurants
are making more wages than
those uh at the very low
um you know there's the mid-range
restaurants
there's the and there's the lower uh
uh range ones and uh certainly there is
that
um and uh you probably don't have
a lot of folks that have been serving um
in those lower ends that stay there very
long unless they're
of course in a part of the state where
there is no high end
um but uh someone that learns the uh
you know at a lower end uh i'll tell you
right now
restaurants are looking to hire people
um
so if you're not happy with the wages
you're making some place
and you want to go make higher wages
there are plenty of employers that will
hire you uh
both at high end mid-range uh so there
are there are options out there
currently i mean
this labor shortage isn't just for the
restaurant industry i think you hear it
statewide health care child care i mean
there just are not enough workers out
there so there currently are plenty of
options
um so if you're a tipped employee at a
restaurant
you're not satisfied with the wages
you're getting there are
a number of options out there uh to move
follow up mr chair
thank you uh well again
you're in a you're in a nice restaurant
and
it's they expect it to be busy but it's
not something else is going on
around town and and they send us they
might send the staff home and you
what happens in that case you get that
327 an hour
and how do you pay your bills so
uh if it's a slow night you get sent
home there is a two hour
minimum that you have to pay so the
employer
you show up and 30 minutes in it's like
all right we're not going to have you
know what's up
you go home the employer has to pay the
um
at least two hours uh of uh
the minimum which is going to be the um
if you didn't make any tips then the
employer will have to pay
7.25 an hour because they got to make
sure
that you walk out of there with at least
7.25 an hour
so if you didn't get any tips you're not
just going to get 327 you're going to
get 7.25 so
there's two hours you make 15 dollars
if you get no tips at all
one more question mr share
thank you i know this i know this is
part of the federal law but i i wonder
that
what you think about this requirement
that the minimum rather minimum
requirement you make thirty dollars
if you're usually and customarily make
thirty dollars a month um
that's that's the threshold for being a
tipped employee
do you think that's out of a date mr
value
uh it was set a long time ago um
could it be higher i suppose um it would
require
you know where where to set it i don't
know it probably requires some work
which would basically you probably have
to retain this bill
uh and work on it which
i would not uh suggest you do that uh i
think this this bill is needed sooner
than later
i'd be happy to work with you uh at
looking at
where that i mean you're correct it's
been 30 dollars in stats for a long time
um could it be higher yeah um
what should it be i don't know uh but be
happy to work with you
thanks very much thank you are there any
other questions
for representation for mr value
seeing none thank you very much
i'm going to take a moment here before i
call the next um
speaker i've always liked to keep things
casual in the labor committee
um always allow people to ask the kind
of questions they'd like to
and i don't like the the riff that's
going on right now
um you know
we probably shouldn't ask the person how
to just
is someone who's representing the
lodging restaurant association
they're asking them a question of how is
someone supposed to pay their bills on
that amount i understand what you're
trying
to say i understand that sometimes these
issues become uh emotional
but we want to keep it to the
appropriate questions
for for our speakers that are asking um
and i think everybody knows what i mean
i'm not going to get into any
any any details i i the whole question
about would you believe has always been
kind of a joke
that we all use when someone asks a
question that really isn't a question
that's making a statement
and then we all say would you believe
and kind of laugh and chuckle at it we
try to move on to the next business
um that came from and
it was a was a parliamentary
parliamentary
presentation put on by could i speak
yeah
well no i swear that comes from this sir
this chair is that is used on the house
floor during debates and it's
it's appropriate there but it is not
appropriate in the experience again i
i want to give everyone a lot of
latitude and ask the questions they want
and i just don't want to cause a riff
when you someone asks a question
that's clearly meant to
make a point and then try to get someone
to
embarrass someone to ask answer your
question that's all we're trying to do
the goal of the executive session all of
us is to learn from our our speakers
so um but i wanted to get back to
to kind of the way we were um
since i brought up two people's name
this is very odd
i'm just gonna keep going for a couple
minutes before we get back because
representative attitude representative
cahill since i did mention some things
there i'm going to let you guys just
respond okay
and then we'll get back to our hearing
so thank you for giving me a little bit
of attitude here
representative madison thank you mr
chairman and i want to clarify
like the point of the would you believe
question is not to embarrass
lawmakers like other representatives or
senator bradley
the purpose of it is when folks come
before this committee
and they say
things like oh oh increasing the minimum
wage
will increase technology in the
workplace and it will lose jobs and all
this
and i have an example of a study from
the economic policy institute or cornell
um that disagrees with that
it would be great in the moment to
have sort of present them with that
information and give them an opportunity
to rebut that
if you know uh they disagree with it or
they have
follow-up information it's the same
thing that representative kuchar did
where he referenced you know the exact
same study that i was referencing
from cornell uh just without the name
so you know i i don't like to do the
gotcha stuff i ask a lot of rhetorical
questions to occasionally make a point
but also
draw that distinction and give an
opportunity for clarification
like my question regarding um
and i agreed with the second question
regarding the charitable gaming folks um
wasn't like a gotcha it was why are we
making an exception for that
and the answer the best we got was
because they asked
i'm okay with someone saying i have
another study that says x
y and z um and could you tell me what
your study is so i can compare the two
um i just don't want to monologue it so
i'm trying to put it into a question
understood representative thank you mr
chair um yeah
mr they and i have known each other for
a couple of years now and
my the question i asked was really no no
disrespect to him
or the restaurant industry it was merely
that you know
they they were told that the restaurant
the tipped workers
make so much the average is this but
there are times when they don't
and that's really what i was trying to
get across no uh
no embarrassment or disrespect intended
all right excellent
thank you for allowing me to deviate for
a second i always want to keep things
copacetic here even when we disagree
so thank you very much oh
go through as best we can the next
up is mr rick newman from the new
hampshire charitable
gaming operations mr newman are you here
good afternoon mr chairman good
afternoon
my name is rick newman i represent the
new hampshire charitable gaming
operators association and i am here in
support
of this legislation and i will be brief
but i can
jump into answering a couple of
questions that have been asked regarding
secondary game operators first i well
just so you know
secondary secondary game operator
licensees
in the charity gaming business are
essentially dealers
so these are the people that would be
dealing cards at a blackjack table or a
poker table or
operating a roulette wheel or a crap
table
those are the positions that come under
that title secondary game operator
and currently they are subject to the
federal minimum wage of seven and a
quarter however
they are a relatively new uh job
uh charity gaming as it exists today
under 287 287d was created in this state
in 2006.
prior to that those jobs did not exist
because charity gaming did not exist
as we have it today so
from the beginning these workers have
made most of their money from tips and
so i believe they're legitimately
tipped employees and that's why we
wanted to take
this opportunity to be included to have
them included
as tipped employees as to why
have their rate at seven and a quarter
versus the
uh weight uh rate uh for weight staff um
same as mr value said we had no
intention of looking to lower
someone's existing minimum wage and
since those folks
are making seven and a quarter uh we
said
let's establish it uh that that rate for
them
um i will tell you that um it now every
room of course is different there are 16
charity gaming facilities in new
hampshire they are small ones ranging
from a very small location up in berlin
uh to a very busy uh locations on the
you know in salem new hampshire in
manchester nashua
um so the rate does vary but the
low end on uh tipped employees or
dealers in those
rooms range between 12 13
an hour in tips up to 35 40
an hour uh in some of the other rooms so
um we are here asking you to include us
in the tip
category and uh hope you will support
that
happy to answer any questions thank you
any questions here in the lobby
i have a question mr newman this is uh
will infantine
these individuals currently are making
seven dollars and 25 cents an hour uh
that
deal and and such correct
that's the minimum for them that's
correct and then
i don't gamble a lot but when i've seen
these things go on someone gets a good
hand
uh they win a pot or something and they
they
toss over a chip or something to the
dealer
that is how they are tipped correct
that's correct
typically that is exactly what happens
particularly in poker if someone wins
the pot
they throw a tip chip to the dealer so
you're proposing to
reduce them from 725
to 327
yeah come tipped employees uh no sir if
you look at the legislation
uh it would establish 725 as the minimum
wage for secondary game operators they
would stay at the seven and a quarter
my apologies for uh any other questions
here the llb
representative seaworth thank you mr
chairman thank you mr newman for your
testimony
um that helps me a lot with my question
i was wondering um if
you were able to shed any light on the
question
representative turcotte asked earlier
about
the next four lines where with a slight
variation
it it repeats what's already there but
applies it to the secondary game
operators do you know
why that language was chosen
representative i read that and it looks
to me like
the bull language is referring to
uh the federal minimum wage and the
language that's not in bold as current
statute
which refers to the quote applicable
minimum wage
um i'm assuming that that's the reason
that's written like that but
uh you know that's something you may
want to check with legislative services
because the federal minimum wage if it
doesn't change
then wouldn't come into play but the
applicable minimum wage in the current
statute
uh language would still apply that's
true
other questions from members online
representative to me followed by
representative schmidt
representative tooney you're recognized
thank you mr chairman
uh thank you mr newman uh is there any
place like the labor department to be
able to find out
what the the uh gaming employees make
in terms of tips i i know that there
might be numbers
in in terms of that in in the case of
waiters and waitresses in
in restaurants is there any place we can
find out what the actual
average uh tipped wage that your your
people get
the only thing i can say representative
is just like a restaurant
um these businesses would file the
necessary uh
tax paperwork for instance on regarding
paying
unemployment tax and so i would assume
the department of employment security
would
have information on those numbers okay
thank you sir
representative smith thank you mr
chairman and thank you very much for
taking my question
um is there a reason that they have to
be called tech
workers just because they receive tips
or can they just
receive their normal 725 or whatever
and accept their tips uh outside being
called a tipped worker
well from our perspective it's you know
there are
differences among tipped employees how
they're treated
in the statute and these folks are
legitimately tipped employees they
certainly make
more than 30 a month in tips they rely
on their tips to make a living
just as you know waitresses waiters do
they're certainly in the same category
and i believe that
had the job existed 50 years ago they
probably would have been included
in the category of tipped employees when
it was created but as i said
because the job is relatively new it
only was created
in 2006 um it just uh you know it's not
there in the statute now
thank you just follow up quickly
it just seems odd that that we'd like to
put somebody new into tipped wages
when this is a questionable um part in
our law a lot of people would like to
see tipped wages just disappear
that people should be treated as
employees period
and no special um government
intervention as to how much
they can be paid is it now i understand
that you see them as tipped
employees but is there any reason that
you want to put them into this statue
besides
just that you see this as tipped
wages one specific reason would be that
unlike every other well i won't say
every
not certain but certainly unlike
virtually all
other employees or businesses you
the legislature have a great deal to do
with
the ability of a charity gaming facility
to
have revenue for instance you cap the
bet limits at currently at ten dollars
and
you know there's a statutory requirement
that charities get 35 percent of the
money and the state gets 10
and so we can't real we can't simply
raise our wages
are or raise our prices the way another
business can so if the feds were to come
in with a 15 or 20 dollar
minimum wage that would have a
tremendous impact
on the owners of these businesses who
would have no ability to offset that
wage increase um
and despite the fact that their
employees were making you know pretty
good tips but
uh they would not be able to just say
well we're going to allow 20 bets now
that's that's subject to the legislature
so
thank you very much i appreciate your
answer thank you
representative representative thank you
mr chairman
following up on what you just said uh
i i'm not an expert in charitable gaming
i was not aware of the
max cap donations
but if the language in here
is um employees should update the
difference to guarantee the federal
statutory that are not really great
so they're still paying for an increase
in the minimum wage anyways
is not the appropriate there is not a
better solution
to that issue to be to revise the
language and statute that you just
referred to
versus inserting language in here that
would then be overridden
by federal legislation
i i have to tell you representative i
apologize but i really don't
understand your question go ahead i
i i i know where you're getting with
just try it again
but my point is like if you're talking
about
the if if you're talking about the
restrictions placed on
institutions that operate charitable
gaming
and we have to insert this language
in the bill to make it
better for those people would not
a better solution be to just amend
those restrictions and possibly allow
the charitable gaming folks to make a
little bit more money
versus inserting language in the bill
that would then just be overwritten by
federal legislation anyways were it to
happen
i i get you i understand your your point
um and i would say to you that uh
i don't um we would certainly support
increasing the
the debt limits at the charitable gaming
locations but that's not the bill in
front of us
and we we just feel assuming that that's
going to remain in
in place as it is today that that this
bill
uh helps us protect our our businesses
any other questions here in the llb
any other questions online
seeing none thank you mr newman i'm
sorry
uh
oh i thought i had mr just
representative
see i'm not getting the avalanche
why aren't i getting that i'm sorry
representative
avalani this is twice for some reason on
my screen i'm not getting your little
yellow hand so representative abalone
and then if toomey has a follow-up
go ahead representative thank you mr
chairman and no worries i'll save my
question my last question for um
uh deputy commissioner ogden um the
question i have
to
i will ask you a question because i'm
sorry to say that i received a text
message from
representative from rudy ogden he has
had to go to another meeting he will not
be able to address us he did
give me something to read but uh i just
wanted to know that so go ahead
oh um the um
the gentleman from the gaming industry i
don't know if he can answer this
question or not but
um if your dealers are paid minimum wage
um how
how or why why or how
do they get to claim their tips over and
above the minimum wage and is there an
ability to do that
claim their tips they would do it
just the way any other tipped employee
does i mean a dealer
reports their tips uh in most cases
because the dealers do
receive their tips directly they report
their tips to the employer the employer
is
mr value said you know then is subject
to pay in the fica tax and
unemployment tax on those tipped wages
just like they would any other wages so
that's how the
other tips are claimed and reported
thank you and follow up mr chairman all
right
um with uh lowering going to a tip wage
which um
would allow you the employer to withhold
those wages through their paycheck
and then pay the applicable taxes
because that's how the irs looks at
shipped employees is if it's below the
minimum wage
uh as 327 you would at least have to
make it to minimum wage
do you does your employer employees now
have the ability to
claim their tips even though they paid
that 7.25 an hour
that's the original question that just
acts differently
yes they uh so the employer currently uh
again that's the minimum of
some dealers make more than 725 but yes
the employer
would withhold taxes from 725 and they
would also
withhold in most cases the 725 would
allow them enough
so that if an employee let's say it's
reported x dollars in tips
the employer calculates the tax due
on that x and also withholds that from
the paycheck of the employee and it's
paid to the appropriate
federal or state agency
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you for the question
did representative tooney have a
follow-up question
no i i forgot to take my hand down but i
do have a request
and a simple request if if people in the
uh
in the uh committee room uh ask a
question or or speak
could they state their name because it's
hard for us to tell who
who was talking thank you you're welcome
uh
we'll do that representative sullivan i
just want to make the suggestion to the
chair
of if you put your computer on gallery
view
we have any other questions here in the
hello being none online thank you mr
newman thank you mr chairman
i have i believe three more people to
speak
uh so for the individuals that are
waiting for our two o'clock hearing
which are now 15 minutes behind
senate bill 123 um the one person i have
senator sue uh prentice we will be with
you as soon as we can
senator um uh
christina has representative kaplan
re-joined us at all or joined us
i do not see him okay next
next uh individual dr gayle
kinney
are you with us
dr gail kinney she just needs to unmute
she is available
okay sorry about the delay there um mr
chairman
and members of the committee i thank you
for the opportunity to testify this
afternoon for the record my name is gail
kinney
i'm a pastor with the meridian
congregational church
and i also represent the economic
justice team of the new hampshire united
church of christ
which is the largest protestant
denomination in the state
i'm testifying on behalf of a number
of voices of faith in new hampshire in
opposition to senate bill 137
and i strongly urge this committee to
find this particular bill
inexpedient to legislate you've already
heard
that this bill was um submitted
in reaction to the fear among some
that the federal minimum wage would be
increased and um the number that's been
bandied about
for months now and discussing this is 15
an hour and many people including
legislators have talked about this is
that somehow
the wage would go up to fifteen dollars
an hour tomorrow or next week and this
was imminent and it was going to happen
immediately
and the reality is if this is a reaction
to the federal
uh raise the wage act which is the
current um
bill which is now before the um the u.s
senate
it talks about a gradual increase in the
minimum wage
that doesn't hit 15 an hour until 2025
so this this myth that all of a sudden
restaurant um owners and and
employers of tipped workers are going to
see 15 that has the potential to see 15
an hour tomorrow is simply a myth and
you should
not be passing legislation based on
based on a myth which is
which is not um based in reality at all
so please don't be misled but the other
thing
is that um again if this was introduced
in reaction to that 15
without it it seems like it was it was
introduced without anyone doing any
research about what is actually
potentially
possibly happening at the federal level
which certainly doesn't seem to be
happening anytime soon
that is the federal raise the wage act
addresses
both on the gradual increase
in the federal minimum wage and a
gradual
increase in tipped wages and the reality
i think again if you do the legislative
research you will know
that that only two things will happen
you know in terms of federal legislation
which will then have an impact on new
hampshire
the first is that there will be that the
raise the wage act which is currently
written
which um talks about an increase uh the
same gradual
increase on in the tipped wage as the
uh minimum wage for non-tipped workers
that's
in one package in the bill right now
that nobody seems to be recognizing
and the other thing is that it's
possible that that
legislation will be introduced that does
away with a tipped
wage and then goes to the concept of one
fair wage for all workers
um and then with without any without
addressing tips
i think that the possibility of that
happening i personally i'd love to see
it happen but
i think the possibility of that
happening is very minimal
and the reality is that the folks will
be working at
looking at some version of the um the
raise the wage act
which does address tipped wages so the
fact that you're trying to do or you're
being asked to do a piece of legislation
which is it's going to be null and void
it's going to be overridden
if this is a in reaction to something
that's happened federally right now
you're dealing with a 725 on minimum
wage and you're dealing with 327 for
tipped workers
and that is the way it's going to be
until something passes federally
and when something passes federally it
is going to be something that addresses
minimum wages and will override this
legislation anyway
so this there's no way that the feds are
going to carve out a minimum wage
without also addressing tipped wages
talk to your federal legislators talk to
people in the know about what's
happening federally
and they will tell you that that's the
case so passing this
bill which is really not going to mean
anything
is not in the best interest of new
hampshire at all
um just the other thing really quickly
to say is
um the the restaurant sector which is
primarily where this is coming from
is um there are so many workers in the
state of new hampshire that
work in that sector and we depend on
them to be good workers
um in order to attract people to come to
our state this is an important sector of
our economy
and to say to them that we are going to
in statute
freeze your wages no matter what the way
they are today
no matter what no matter what increases
there are and the cost of living or
anything else
what is saying what is that saying to
those workers it just seems it strikes
me
as a wage freeze put into statute
is telling those workers that you are
losing
somebody talked i think senator bradley
talked about winners and losers
i think putting this in statute would
say we consider you to be losers
the other thing is that we are not
talking about just
first time job seekers or or entry level
on
people working you go into any
restaurant and you will see people of
all ages
people with families etc that are trying
to work to to earn a living wage
but are doing a job they love um just
i want to also say that a very extensive
studies have been done
over the years using department of labor
and u.s equal employment opportunity
commission
on statistics and data and i want to
read you the subheading of one of the
studies
the subheading is just the data is
overwhelming
tipping encourages racism sexism
harassment and exploitation so we
already know that chipped workers of
color are often chip less
female workers must often must put up
with sexual harassment
in new hampshire in order to make a
decent wage
wage theft is happens in this particular
industry
in terms of employers actually
appropriately paying out the tips
it's an industry problem on top of that
this work is
hard work so to freeze
the wages in statute of this particular
sector of employees
is just it's so immoral
um based on the people that i am um
speaking for
uh and the fact that this this
legislation itself
is just nonsensical in terms of what's
happening at the federal level
i encourage you just to put this bill
aside and uh
and to not spend your your valuable time
dealing with it anymore
i also just want to pose a question am i
understanding correctly
that the idea is to pull that particular
category of
um charitable gaming workers into a
definition of what a chipped worker
is so um and so that their
wages their overall wages will be frozen
at 7.25 an hour even if the minimum wage
goes up so what the federal
raise the wage act says that the next um
progression i think is going to be 9.50
an hour is what that that particular um
piece of legislation talks about
so what but with this is what this bill
doing then
saying that those particular workers
will not be eligible
for the 9.50 an hour if that becomes the
federal minimum wage because
this legislature has frozen their wages
at 7.25
their base wage so it's just a question
i have because i'm not quite
understanding what you're being told
about that
but in any event you've heard me say
that this is
unnecessary legislation and i implore
you to just set it aside and vote in
expedient to legislate
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for the presenter
in the lob representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my
question the
is it accurate to say that uh the uh
act would increase to the tipped minimum
wage
to 495 in 2021
yes that is correct and so that would
supersede anything that you would try to
put in statute
thank you any other questions here in
the lobby
see none or any questions online for the
presenter
and yellow hands i can't see
say none thank you very much for your
presence for your testimony
okay and thank you i really appreciate
the opportunity
the next up is uh
asthma el huni from the rights and
democracy group
are you with us
i do not see her asma is the first name
is the last name yes i don't see her on
the call
okay do we have uh a
lobbyist by the name of curtis berry
with us
yes i'll bring him right up thank you
good afternoon good afternoon you're
recognized to speak
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee good afternoon i'm curtis
barry
here on behalf of the cigar association
of new hampshire which is
a coalition of 10 locations retail shops
in new hampshire that
sell premium cigars five of which have a
cigar bar license
similarly to the charitable gaming
operators the cigar bar license
in the statute was put in place in 2009
many decades after the creation of this
statute which listed
um as you see on the bill starting on
line
five uh the categories of industries
that are eligible for the tipped wage
we simply ask uh to be included in that
because
their servers are similarly tipped and
and make very good wages
and make very good tips there and
similarly
like the other industries that you heard
from this afternoon
are very concerned about an increase at
the federal level
the same effects apply here
as you heard earlier uh and i don't have
anything
in addition to say other than
i would like to be included in that um
in that statute
other than to say and to remind the
committee
that line 19 of the bill exists this is
a contingency
it only applies if the federal law is
passed
i'm happy to answer questions to the
best of my ability or provide
information subsequent to the hearing
thank you mr barry any questions for him
in
the lob
are there any online
i have one question for you mr berry
certainly if this bill were to pass
and the federal government increased the
minimum wage to ten dollars in the tip
weights of five dollars
ours would automatically have to
go up to that or would we have to
don't they does the federal government
usually give the states a time period in
which they must ratify
that or does that happen automatically
uh
mr chair to be honest with you i'm not
sure which
of those two scenarios would apply um
but i'm happy to work with you to find
out the answer
all right thank you very much are there
any other questions
all right thank you very much christina
is there anyone else wishing to testify
i don't see any hands currently up
all right seeing none it is 2
28 i'm going to close the hearing on
senate bill
137 i apologize i have to say one thing
i
i'm losing it definitely losing it i
would like to read something
from um mr ogden
i'm just going to find whether he
emailed me or
mr ogden deputy commissioner of the
university department of labor
we apologize he had to unfortunately
leave the one concern we have this is a
quote
the one concern we have on this
is if the fed raises the tipped rate
period it will cause confusion and we
the dol
would not be able to directly address
those that do not pay the raised amount
they would run a foul of the feds but we
would not be able to address it
um so i'm gonna try to get clarification
for what that is based on my last
question i just asked
um and i will
have um mr ogden email
everyone
[Music]
and i think at this point
you really can't testify we can't all
you know so um
in an executive session that could come
up but i hope i hope to get some
clarification from
mr ogden uh in an email to all of us to
follow up on his
testimony he was not able to get and
then you'd all be able to answer
questions representative sullivan
since we can't um go back and forth with
mr ogden on an email due to right to
know
would it be appropriate for him to uh
come to the executive session too
i mean it's a little bit unorthodox to
uh testify but since
it seems like he's got concerns and
we're not really clear about them
that would be a public meeting and he
could
[Music]
i think we can do both if anyone has
i will ask him to um anyone can
based on what i just said anyone is
able to contact him individually to get
the question answered
i have no problem with having a
department head
here to speak at the beginning part of
an executive session i've done it before
and it's proven to be um
[Music]
appropriate and positive so i can do
that
thank you any other questions before i
close the hearing on
senate bill 137 seeing none thank you
session on how 37 is over
we will open the hearing on senate bill
123 relative to employer payment for
required covid testing
for all the representatives house bill
senate bill 123 had a significant
amendment make sure you are reviewing
the amendment when we have the
discussions
i only have one individual signed up to
testify
that is senator sue prentice from senate
district five
senator are you with us good afternoon
chairman infantine i
am with you i am very sorry for the wait
oh it certainly is fine um i've
we've we've all been at that side we're
waiting
so it's all good thank you um so
if you're all said i'll get started yes
please
um so good afternoon for the record my
name is suzanne prentiss i'm the
state senator for district five and um
chairman infantine i'm also a um a
fellow purple knight you and i are both
graduates of the class of 1986. um
so i wanted to just uh give a shout out
to st
mike's and also greetings to two of rep
two reps from my district
uh representative adjutant and
representative sullivan i am here today
to introduce senate bill 123
and this is relative to the employer
payment of required covid19
testing and this is a bill that i worked
on with senator tom
sherman we both had received concerns
from constituents
who were being required to have
a covid19 test to either return to work
or as a condition of employment
but they did not have insurance or the
means
um to they didn't have insurance or the
means to pay for it um again this was a
requirement
so we um we actually
talked with some representatives from
the industry as well as the insurance
department
and thought that the best way to do this
and that's how this amendment came about
was to align this under chapter 275
which is the protective legislation
to read that it should be unlawful
for an employer as defined in rsa 275
4 to require any employee or applicant
for employment to pay the cost of a
coveted 19 test
as a condition of employment i think
it's important to note that this
is this is important for the workforce
um
and i just heard some of the last
testimony about you know a
workforce and and and wages
and tipped workers and i just want to
think about it in
somewhat of that framework um as well as
this is good for
members of the public and our customers
to know
and i've often noted right now when i
like might pull up to a certain
restaurant locally for takeout
that there is a sign that says you know
we are a um
we are a safe workplace our employees
are screened
they're tested i mean i think this is a
consumer confidence and a workforce
issue
or workforce protection at the same time
so
with that i am happy to take any
questions to the
to the best of my ability and if i don't
have the answer i'd be happy to get back
to you thank you
thank you senator are there any
questions here in the lobby
senator sullivan you recognized
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
senator france
um
i did read the original uh version of
the bill um
it's far more complex than um the
current
uh version he has amended was the
purpose of amending this
just to accomplish the same thing in a
much simpler way
thank you for the question
representative sullivan exactly
in fact this was originally part of
senate bill 132
which was an omnibus covid
bill and we realized that 123 was asking
for the same thing
uh but in a more complex way so we
amended it out of the other bill came
over here and i joined
senator sherman so thank you for the
question exactly
thank you yes thank you
it's much easier to read online
senator cahill
thank you for the promotion mr chair
can i get a raise with that well
probably not thank you uh
senator apprentice for taking my
question i also read the original bill
we've talked about a co-payment waiver
uh so that the uh person the employee
wouldn't have to pay
the cost and with this
it does say the cost review it's it
would be the employer that would pay the
cost
um of this and i would i'd like to
point out that in the current statute
under 275 and again thank you for your
question
um that there is a similar provision um
and so it's 275.3 which makes it
unlawful for an employer
again as defined in 275 for to require
an employer an applicant from employment
to pay the cost of a medical examination
or the cost of furnishing any records
required by the employer as a con
condition of employment so it would be a
cost to the employer if they are
requiring this
again for their safe workplace and it is
consistent with language
and another part of the statute thank
you very much
you're welcome
senator huff you recognized i'm sorry
representative
promotion wow um
senator apprentice my question is
it's my understanding that if an
employer is going to ask for a test
that they're
expecting to find out the results of
that test
and i bring that up because it's also my
understanding that hipaa
would prohibit an employer from getting
any information medical
that the employee didn't want released
to them
so if they theoretically are never going
to get the answer to the question that
they're making them do
what is the purpose of having this bill
representative thank you for your
question so
i think hipaa um theoretically i don't
think that hipaa crosses this because if
you've consented
and you are agreeing as a condition of
employ you know this is a condition of
employment
and that information would have to be
shared but i can confirm that
thank you
do i see any other questions for the
senator um
anyh in the lob
i do not any online
are you not thank you very much senator
we appreciate your oh
well my last minute representative
cahill
you're on youtube michael abalani's also
on there
representative avilani has his hand up
you know i did what i was told to by
representative sullivan i did gallery i
still don't see the pretty little yellow
hands
so i apologize again um represent
you recognize to speak no follow mr
chairman thank you very much
senator for taking my question um if an
employee
as an employer if an employee has an
outside event let's just say for covert
19.
um their family members come home then
they're infected or
however it is and they have to get
tested if an employer asks for the
results of that test would they be
required to pay for that test
because you know
technically they couldn't come back to
work without it with the executive
orders and the
guidance that we have right now so thank
you
representative a lot of your questions i
think a train went by in the middle of
that
there's a train track right near his
restaurant unfortunately
that's a that's an excellent question i
mean if they have had
um we could i think we could probably
take a step further to clarify this if
they went to an outside event that was
not work related
as people do um and they were
potentially exposed
and got tested you know it's
there um it's there you know you have
there's a difference between whether
you're acquiring this or not so let's
say you're not requiring this
but you ask them is the courtesy to
share the result but this is making it
you know unlawful for the payment if you
require
them to take the test so if you say you
know i'm requiring you to do this
um and they haven't already taken it
then it would be up to you but
i think let me talk to um the assistant
commissioner over
in labor and see what his opinion would
be on that
i'd be happy um chairman infant i don't
know if you want to get
if you want me to get back to you or
directly to um representative avenatti
but i'd be happy to clarify that that's
an excellent question
yeah senator if you wouldn't mind um uh
just sending it to me please and i will
pass it
on committee yep i'd be happy to great
question thank you
thank you any follow-up representative
i just want to know if the training was
on time it was actually a little bit
early i was hoping to get on and
and have it go by usually goes by around
three but no thank uh thank you mr
chairman that question was um
the only one that i had thank you and
thank you senator you are so welcome
any other questions online
seeing none any lob
sing john thank you senator you're
welcome and hey thank you very much
representative infantine uh this was
definitely worth the wait and i'll get
back in touch with you
okay thank you
i'm embarrassed to say my fellow
classmate i didn't realize was a senator
i apologize for not knowing that senator
um
christina do we have any other people
waiting to testify online
currently there's no one with a hand up
i'm sorry as i'm getting older i'm
getting deaf i did not hear you
no no other hands thank you thank you
all right so seeing no other people
willing to testify
i'm going to close the hearing on
senate bill 123.
any other business of a committee nature
that anyone would like to bring up or
ask of the chair any questions here in
the lob
any questions uh representative bouchard
you're on moved on
i just wanted to be called senator
bouchard okay
he's here i i will let you know that i
will unfortunately be traveling the next
few weeks
and i will not be here the next uh a few
wednesdays or thursdays so
you'll be hearing from um
representative seaworth about
when the uh executive session is going
to be
uh initially i was hoping to do it next
week being
that we're still waiting to hear from
senator apprentice on a few things and
rudy ogden
i'm going to um suggest that we do that
the following week
and i'll coordinate to see if i can
either be here or not
with uh the vice chairman representative
edison
thank you mr chairman uh just in the
interest of schedule like i would ask
um
let's just look at a calendar real
quickly here
i want to get back to thursday as this
was done on a specific wednesday i did
talk to representative for rudy to make
sure he could make it
because i know thursday it seems to be
the the best day for everyone that we
discussed at the beginning
of the year i was trying to accommodate
the department of labor as well the 19th
is a wednesday
i my goal would be um
to do this either the 26th or the 27th
or either the 20th or the 27th probably
um
we do the 27th it's the last you know
has to be done that day
that if we do that you know we're
pushing it just be done by the 29th
or the 28th one concern that i would
have
everyone yep
um but uh my wife was really sick
of your second shot and
[Music]
i don't want to be a situation where
votes go a different way because people
can't make it especially because of
getting their shots so
let's uh aim for the 26th or the 27th
and we will let you know exactly which
date okay
all right any questions online folks
all right senator bouchard thank you
appreciate it
we'll uh we'll catch you guys next week
and representative susie i just don't
have an answer for you yet
as soon as i get one i'll send i'll call
you
thank you mr chairman all right have a
good day everyone